one and we should be live chairman thank
you
Thank You Aaron gender item one good
afternoon and welcome to this district
planning committee meeting on Thursday
the 9th of July 2020
my name is councillor Bob boyce and I am
the chairman of this committee this
remote meeting is held under new
regulations which came into effect on
the 4th of April in response to the go
bid 19 situation there are a few
housekeeping issues to run through
including a new working practices which
have been implemented due to the
pandemic and the etiquette for this
meeting first of all please could I'll
serve anyone present in this meeting to
ensure your microphone remains muted and
your video feed off we're not addressing
the committee this will reduce
background noises and avoid any
unintentional and intentional
disturbances this meeting will be hosted
remotely via conferencing software which
allows members of the public to
virtually attend the meeting whilst
being able to protect themselves and
others and observe the government's
lockdown measures we might encounter
some glitches this afternoon so I hope
that everyone will bear with us as we
get used to this new way of working we
are streaming this meeting live as well
as recording and by being present in the
meeting you're giving your consent to
being recorded members and officers
during each item please use the chat
function of the meeting to indicate if
you wish to speak oh well then invite
you at the appropriate time members are
reminded that apart from indicating you
wish to speak or that you have to leave
the meeting the chat function should not
be used for any other purpose the
processes afternoon will obviously be
different and for some items I might
invite each member to speak in turn
therefore I would encourage all members
to keep your contribution as clear and
concise as possible please when speaking
and referring to the agenda papers
please ensure your reference a page or
paragraph number but I ensure that
everyone is tutorial connected to a
power supply
so that nobody drops out due to short
battery life and Laos if members need to
leave this meeting at any point please
make this known and use the chat
function to signify that you need to
leave the meeting now we'll all ask
office as a present to introduce
themselves starting with Matt Lee good
afternoon members and members of lick
I'm Matthew Lee and I'm lead specialist
place a more District Council you're
very distant my apologies councillor
good evening afternoon councillors my
name is Michael Johnson lead specialist
development management
good afternoon members I'm Devin Hannah
and a specialist in development
management miss Matthews
Thank You chairman glass noon I'm
Kathleen Matthews their specialist in
development management i'm tara yourself
and any other officers are present good
afternoon chairman I'm Tara bird QT
services officer to the meeting thank
you thank you
is there anybody else present Tara
officers and not unaware of chairman no
I'm I'm getting lots of messages of
people losing connection um right now
Tara will you please call the roll of
members to confirm who who's in
attendance thank you yes time remembers
and usual if a beatnik we're actually
just confirm you're here please you've
started accounts the Bamford yes present
Tara Thank You councillor Basinger good
afternoon yes present Tara he casa me
spiel pression that's the brian bill
well here Tara missus channel wasn't at
the moment or cats dick
apologies for absence
that's the dawn present thank you
Edwards present that's the mrs. Fleming
present so you can I believe he was on
chairman Buzzard
Thank You councillor Harker present Pat
present thank you
cats the helm frozen
Oh My servants cats with Jarvis
president thanks Tara you cats and I can
present things Tara cats amazed present
morning present Tara but voice I need
saving the Internet thank you very much
cats and mice good afternoon and welcome
thank you
canceling them presents Farah you can't
see mr. Shaughnessy present Tara thank
you you cats little present
Thank You cats the scanners good
afternoon everybody
that's the step present Tara but I'm on
the iPad so I may have trouble
communicating Tara today so I do
apologize okay no - thank you cancer
stilts present cancer suede B cancer
mrs. Thompson counselor mrs. Thompson
sorry sorry
thank you and counselor mr. white
apologies are used to put you through
see from counselor keys thank you to
agenda item three minutes of the last
meeting we need something turn off their
microphones matter it's Maddie it's
Maddie Thompson implied morally they're
together again
can we stop the inter chair the minutes
of the meeting held on the 3rd of June
2020 found on pages 7 to 12 our agree to
an accurate record and I so move is that
second it
yeah great a second did the grave is
there is a with this yes
breathe thank you that that's the agenda
item three
now agenda item four declarations of
interest to disclose the existence and
nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interest other pecuniary interest or
non-pecuniary relating to items of
business on the agenda having regard to
paragraph six to eight inclusive of the
code of conduct for members members are
reminded that they are also required to
disclose any such interest as soon as
they become aware should the need arise
throughout the meeting if the only
member has an interest of declare please
use the chat function and indicate and I
will invite you to speak now I've
probably got several now so I know
councillor Mays wishes to declare an
interest
yes thank Thank You mr. chairman yes a
non-pecuniary interest in item five as I
know the owner of Knowles form and in
item six as I am part of the Bradwell
working group thank you
and I know mrs. chana this is chana
sorry Sherman had a bit of difficulty
there couldn't get Machat to register on
both chairman I'm going to declare
obviously the first one of the planning
application Essex County Council because
I've obviously they're consulted on
matters and obviously the the relief
Road and areas like that and also on the
Brad well obviously I'll declare I'm an
Essex County Council that and obviously
they're involved in the jmb be was more
than I don't sit on it but I am aware
obviously that there's some Joint
Working or boards of between Essex to do
with burn oil I mean a job thank you
mrs. Channing councillor Darrin I'm
having the job to keep up but everybody
seems to be declaring an interest you're
doing a jolly good job chairman chairman
I have a non-pecuniary interest in
today's meeting as a member of s
County Council I'm also a deputy cabinet
member for economic development which
includes planning and I am a member of
the jmb the joint members Bradwell board
which is a joint board between modern
district council and Essex County
Council okay thank you
yes chairman and as chairman agenda item
six as chairman and the braaap will be
working group and a member of jmb I will
leave the meeting at the end of gender
item five councillor Fluker so chairman
yeah Jenna item six I'm a member of the
JMP P and the member the rep will be
working good number [ __ ] we think I have
countless schemes and Basinger yes I'm a
member of the bread will be working
group and non-pecuniary interest in
agenda item six the same as councilor
schemes I'm a member of the Brat world
be working group McHenry Thank You
councillor laggin Thank You chair just
to be on the safe side I've had some
conversations some local groups who
object to the proposed work
non-pecuniary thank you and councillor
Thompson and white councillor Thompson
sorry everyone else's so I think I'd
better I wasn't aware it was an interest
really but I am a member of J and B B
and the bread will be working group of
them they're actually not directly
related to this application but not
peculiar anyway thank you
counselor wipes Thank You chairman just
say that I sit on the JM BB and the
bread working group and I don't think
it's an interest but everybody was
noting it so I will note it so we can
put it as an opportunity interest but I
will vote on this matter
Thank You counselor hell yes thank you
mr. chair Thank You non-pecuniary Tara
is there anybody else
everybody gets registered in my chat
they wish to speak right I wish to
declare an interest in that although I
agree with nuclear power in principle
and for reasons that are probably not
planning reasons I have concerns about
agenda item six so I will be abstaining
in that vote for my personal vote right
thank you we can now go on to agenda
item 5 which is land north west of
Knowles farm we kill Maldon found on
pages 13 to 134 please note that a
member update in relation to this
application has been also circulated
prior to the meeting contained on pages
3 to 6
can I call upon miss Matthews pleased to
present the report thank you Kevin
I think I've shared my screen everyone
see the presentation yes okay planning
application for mixed development
persisting 320 or up to 320 new homes
employment land community uses
and a new relief road ancillary
developments on land north and west of
Knowles farm in modern and that drawing
there shows the location and extent of
the application site so this site is
site to be on on the next plan and that
forms part of the southward Garden
Suburb so sites to a is the eastern and
western parcels and to a is currently
being built out by Taylor Wimpey and on
the east on the West that's Chris
Nicholson has has bought that site and
site site to see is linden homes
development has has now been completed
so this site forms part of the strategic
master plan for the south south modern
garden suburb and the area the site
application is pointed to that drawing
the application is accompanied by a
number of drawings indicative drawings
so this is an indicative phasing planned
testing that the site could select out
into in four phases and we've got
land-use parameter plan and so the
yellow land is residential they've got
some blue cross hatch land which is the
employment land and then perfectly
colored across land and the north air
which is the community land so the and
another parameter plan accessing River
plan so you've got the possible location
of the relief Road in in gray landscape
parameter plan the logging story Heights
would all be set as part of the
application so the dog color is the
higher built the greater Hut building
heights and then they're going down to
their lighter blue being the
single-story
residential density parameter plan again
that would be set and the high density
the darker purple color and the lower
density the lighter purple color and the
applications had an interested master
plan and then highways drawings with
applications this is the roundabout that
is exists outside the limited home site
and there's some photos of that
roundabout if that helps and there would
be another roundabout and this would
this would form part of the relief road
which will go off to the north outside
Limehouse farm and then there'll be
another Junction with the relief road on
to wick Hill and north of North Knowles
farm so some photos of the site making
just fields currently
so the purpose of the report for members
consideration today is as an update of
the report that was considered in March
27th 2017 so in March 2017 there was a
resolution to grant permission for the
same development the subject of members
liberation today subject to 106 and
subject to conditions because that 106
has never been signed they because of
ongoing discussions between the County
Council hallways and and the applicants
and the pallium Commission has not been
granted so the purpose of the report
today as I said is to update members on
planning issues that have risen since
March 2017 so very brief summary which
we'll set out in the report so the NPP f
has has been revised since 2017 the
local plan has now been approved and
adopted the modern design guides have
been adopted as a SPG I've got a new
vehicle parking standards adopted the
five-year lands housing land supply for
the district has been maintained
there's updates to the relevant planning
history for the site and and the
neighboring sites and advice has been
received from Natural England regarding
to the Essex cope recreational
disturbance of audience and mitigation
strategy more commonly known as rams
ecology we felt that this could be dealt
with my conditions and the South Molton
relief Road at the time of the last
committee it was in visits that the
applicant would be constructing the
relief Road and but since that time it
has been decided it would be much more
easier and make more sense the County
Council and actually built the road so
they would pull the financial
contributions and then construct the
relief Road on on the applicants land in
terms of air quality and noise they felt
any changes related to that could be
dealt with by conditions the overall
summary so we've got
occasion for up to 320 houses including
affordable housing there's an element of
employment land and we've got an element
of community uses open space their
contributions towards the city
infrastructure including education early
years the relief Road off site highway
improvements public transport use
facilities plate revision health
allotments and rams and this is a final
site in the South Molton Garden Suburb
the other two sites of nabina approved
and then and there is a site linden home
site which has been approved and built
out and these facilitate the delivery of
the relief Road site is allocated for a
minimum of three hundred units in the
LDP so it will make associated
contribution to the council's five-year
housing land supply and the application
is consistent with the requirements of
the MPP F the local development plan and
the infrastructure delivery plan which
fourth part of the local plan as well as
the principles of the framework believe
the leader wishes to do a point of
clarification leader thanked German I
speak actually as the walk member for
South Minister at these meetings can you
officer confirm the Essex County Council
are legally obliged through the 106
agreement to deliver and build the South
Morden relief Road miss Matthews Thank
You chairman the the the 106 will
require a financial contribution from
the developer and towards the projection
the relief Road and I said before the
that contribution along with the others
that have already been secured would be
pulled and pulled pulled and together
and
used by the County Council to build
their relief road but there there would
not be any time frame within exact
timeframe within the the 106 for that to
and when the obligation that they are
working with the modern council to
deliver their relief Road in accordance
with the infrastructure plan which has
already been agreed and there's four
part of the local development plan thank
you right now under the council's public
we have received one submission in line
with the public participation skiing
having reviewed the submission I will
now ask mr. Johnson to read it out mr.
Johnson Driss Thank You chairman the
submission is from Nikolas man the
applicant I made this statement as the
managing director of Dartmouth Park
estates the applicant who has promoted
the wick Hill North site for housing and
associated development for more than a
decade from the outset we fully engaged
in both the preparation of your councils
local plan and strategic master plan
framework leading to the site being
allocated for a minimum of three hundred
homes as one of three strategic
allocations that make up the South
molding Garden Suburb in March 2017 your
council resolved to grow up planning
permission for our outlying planning
application for up to 320 homes
businesses and community uses and the
South Maldon relief Road
we have been discussion discussing the
section 106 with both your council and
county care
or since mainly on the terms for the
construction and delivery of the relief
road but also the 30% affordable housing
and other obligations proposed in 2017
all the obligations agreed then are
before you today plus the more recent
rams contribution requirement this
includes both providing land within the
site to accommodate the road and
disjunctions and their financial
contribution toward its construction
which SS county council highways intend
to do by 2028 the delivery of all three
hundred and twenty homes prior to the
relief road and that essex county
councils can construct the road under a
single subsequent highways contract
unlocks the delivery of housing and
other development and infrastructure at
the site I am talking with potential
house builders for the new health hub
also assuming an approval today and
outline permission in August our program
and visitors development commencing in
2022
with the first sixty dwellings being
delivered in 2023 twenty four and the
remaining home delivered thereafter as
we reflect it in your councils five-year
housing land supply I look forward to
continuing to work with your council and
Essex County Council to released a plan
LED shared vision to provide in
beautiful new homes a relief road
community use and business development
within a vibrant and distinctive new
neighborhood within the South Molton
Garden Suburb are therefore welcome your
officers conditional recommendation
which I trust the committee will endorse
thank you for listening thank you chuck
right thank you
now I'm going to move this
recommendation is that seconded
absolutely seconded thank you
right now I have a list of speakers I
think starting with councillor maize
cows amazed
yes thank you very much mr. chairman um
I've only got a couple of questions at
this point what percentage of the
overall houses are going to be
affordable is one question and what
happens if there is insufficient money
in in the pot from 106 to actually fund
this road that would be desperately
needed for this particular development
Thank You mr. chairman I'm reminded that
I should remind members that there is an
amendment to conditions and informative
detailed on the members update Thank You
councillor maze
mr. Matthews do you want to answer the
question about the affordable housing at
this stage yes chairman the the
affordable housing requirement would be
30 percent which is policy policy
compliant and the housing section of
modern counselor there's no objections
to to the application on that basis and
in terms of so in terms of what happens
if there isn't enough money in the pot
for the relief road then but the that
money no they don't need to be many
found from other sources and there is a
potential source of extra funding from
the North Bay Bridge developments which
is being investigated but that is that
is a matter that will need to be ironed
out subsequent to any being granted and
once it's established exactly how much
the road will cost a build because there
might be there may well be enough money
in the pot but and when it's been
established exactly how much many it
will cost to build the road and the size
of the shortfall if there is any can
then be assessed and alternative means
of funding and investigating
you wanna come back mr. chairman just
one quick question yeah thank you
clearly there there is going to be an
issue with with the funding at what
point if any would the road be put in ie
a halfway through the the whole
development or at the end of the
development or has that not been agreed
at this point I thought it was a
supplementary on but it's a different
question miss Matthews Joe chairman
would show me to pick that one up yes
members need to be aware that this is an
outline planning application and matters
such as phasing and things that had to
be agreed further through conditions or
reserve matters as explained in a poll
the with or less explain my book which
robach slightly even further the
provision of new dwellings won't
automatically require the first few
houses won't automatically required a
vision of a road so there'll be a
phasing process that will ensure that as
the new the number of new dwellings come
forward it doesn't have a detrimental
impact to an outset degree on the local
highway network and that's obviously
what the point of the relief road is is
to mitigate that harm so it won't be in
place before the first house is occupied
and there will be a face and in there
this could in theory stumble and mean
that not all of the dwellings could be
brought forward what members need to
cause obviously that when assessing the
funding required for the road at the
time of the LDP it was accepted that the
worst case scenario level of figure
would not be delivered through the LTP
sites this was some of the council
agreed and accepted news as a
appropriate risk the funding that is
delivered through this site and the
other sites will meet what was seen as i
fairly precautionary but not
unbelievably precautionary approach and
figure so as as Matthews explained
currently we're looking at it
and accounts looking at facilitating the
exact figure so we don't know the exact
thing we don't know if there is a
shortfall but it's it's quite likely
there may not be a shortfall as long as
it doesn't become a worst case scenario
but as explained even if it was that
would then mean that all of the
dwellings wouldn't come forward so it
should not result in a dimensional
impact on the local highway network that
makes sense to members Thank You
chairman yes thank you very much mr.
chairman thank you mr. Navin
thank you Miss Matthews will you remove
your slide from the screen please thank
you very much
and it might be useful sometimes to have
the slide of the the site and what's
going on but at the moment I've got mrs.
Bamford next this is councillor Bamford
Thank You chairman firstly I can't see
the update is that possible to put that
on the screen because I can't act this
everything on the iPad now I I must say
I'm a bit confused about this we have
already approved the housing so in my
mind this is not about the housing this
is about the road and whether this is
going to be actually happy whether this
will actually happen or not I can see on
page 22 of the report at five ten twelve
there are various conditions going
forward which don't seem to pull in part
as a section 106 so my first question is
is there some kind of formal agreement
being drawn up between Essex County
Council and moulding District Council
with regard to the negotiations over the
how this road is going to actually be
constructed because my reading of this
is that there will be no Road at all
until we have 320 extra houses
although as mr. Elias said if there is a
problem then we might have to
temporarily arrange some kind of other
accesses and arrangements well this
doesn't appears to me to be very
satisfactory there is also on pages 26
and 27 reference to the strategic
phasing plan and highway conditions and
I worry that those have been changed or
not because it seems to me the original
strategic phasing plan was that the
parts of the road would be constructed
as the houses were built so we're
talking about a totally different
arrangement now we already know that the
rows of Modan are pretty bad and as more
houses a bill is going to get worse so
I'm not very happy about agreeing this
German but I'd like some clarification
on those points that I've raised thank
you Miss Matthews please and thank you
chairman in terms of the update that was
being asked about I do have an update
but all fit onto one one screen but the
update basically was recommended
condition number eight had a formatting
issue ecology it was recommended that
there was an extra requirement in there
to link in with the habitats regulation
says no it's being carried out for the
application and in terms of the
informative again that was just a
correction in terms of really referring
to the
that the Linden roundabout hasn't been
quite finished exactly how the drawings
show yet and but that was just a
correction rather than substantial that
[Music]
there's a question about whether the
phasing plan has changed as part of the
application when it was considered in
2017 there was an indicative strategic
plan submitted with the application that
was always indicative and it was always
intended that the actual facing pan as
mr. Lee's mentioned already was to be
approved subsequently and eight requires
that to happen so that that phasing plan
would would have to be approved by the
council and be always submitted to the
council
either before any reserved matters are
submitted or at least at the same time
so it would be that at that point they
would be looking at the phasing in with
the highway network and infrastructure
that's also proposed as part of the
application the comment about the
residential has already been approved
that this it's an allocated site in the
local plan so it has been approved in a
vertical manner as part of that process
and there's a council resolution to
grant permission for the application
which includes the residential and but
the permission hasn't been issued to
date as explained earlier and in terms
about the the road the delivery of the
road and when that would happen
again as mr. di said already that would
be a matter that would be dealt with as
I park the approval of the details
required by by condition eight and that
will be based on the most up-to-date
traffic information that the County
Council has and the and this suppose the
other point that's worth mentioning is
this relief Road isn't isn't really for
this development and this is fairly
small in comparison with certainly the
South more than Gordon suburb as a whole
and the North habeas God suburb so in
terms of linking it to the delivery of
this site and that's that's not not
quite accurate and because it's more to
do with the much larger numbers of
houses elsewhere in the garden suburb
and also it's designed to take some of
the traffic that the north garden may be
server board would generate as well I
think I think thank you and that is the
on page 22 at five ten twelve
it's about the negotiations between the
County Council and our council with
regard to the road is there going to be
some kind of legal or agreement and to
facilitate this because it doesn't seem
to be in any sort of documentation it
soon the recommendation though I think
yes but it's not it's not a formal
document between us and this it's County
Council that's what I wanted to know mr.
chairman as 5.10 point twelve goes on to
explain we will deal with it through the
section 106 which is a legally binding
document the heads of terms within the
offices report and the exact wording
will be a bit well sorted out between
the lawyers as in with all search
six agreements Thank You chairman but
now I've got mrs. Shaughnessy next
followed by the other world member I
think councillor heard and then I've got
about six more members at wish to speak
councillor Shaughnessy register
non-pecuniary interest as I know what
one of the people one of the locals who
are against this I don't think my
message got through originally so I
would just like to register a
non-pecuniary there thank you
yes it is mine and councillor Ward
chairman as you mentioned I'm really my
personal opinion is that this proposal
is not really being well thought out a
positive that I have picked out about it
is that all the trees and hedges are to
be are to remained which i think is
great and one of my questions will be
will this be monitored please thank you
and I have two quite specific issues
here chairman thank you
now it says in the text I believe it's
in five point six it says that that the
consider the amenity of neighboring
properties so I just like to bring that
to people's attention and then I would
like to say there is already a natural
bridleway going right across the site
past the residents known as wincroft and
this bride away goes right through to
the four one four so why is this not
being used instead of Lee proposed more
dangerous but a bride away or on the the
wick Hills sort of section of it and why
are three-story buildings
proposed right next to wincroft
it seems very unfair and they are
squeezed in between this residents and
the potential relief road one of these
buildings even curving if anyone cares
to look at the map right towards the
boundary of wincroft this does seem very
unfair as there is plenty of space in
the rest of the development for these
higher buildings and where is the six
meter buffer here as well and I have
three questions for the officers Thank
You chairman
will there be boundary planting for
current residences a long wick Hill and
what about earth banks is that a
possibility to reduce traffic noise from
the four one four and when the relief
road is ever built
will there be provision also for a horse
crossing from line Brook Farm to the
bridle way because the Linden roundabout
impedes their view at the moment so I'd
like to ask those questions
chairman thank you mr. Shaughnessy you
asked those three questions but I
believe you also asked probably two or
three more questions in your speech but
Miss Matthews will you pick up on all
the points that this is showing us he
has built up Thank You chairman um I'll
try to yes monitored yes again and I was
probably a response to some of the other
questions are asked in terms of the in
terms of details like that there are
conditions recommended and there will be
a landscaping condition and information
and details about where or the existing
lands
can propose landscaping and how that
would be maintained and and retained in
the future if the development wasn't
carried out in accordance with their
details don't be dealt with in the
normal way through our enforcement
offices and the next question was about
the bridleway and and why why we're not
using the existing bridleway through the
site access movement and which shows so
that has got a bride way the orange
dotted line yeah so that's the bride way
that part the existing proposed through
through the site and that's what's been
that was submitted part of the original
application and that was part of the
resolution to grant permission for the
development back in March 2017 so that
hasn't hasn't changed in terms of
buffers and possible earth banks and
three-story buildings being close to
existing residents again the these
parameter plans story height parameter
plan again it's a very broad brush
parameter plan so the details in terms
of exactly where those three-story
buildings would go and he's up to three
stories it doesn't necessarily mean that
they would all be three stories they
would they would come forward as part of
any reserved matters application and be
assessed and by proving the application
today is not agreeing to three-story
houses or buildings being right up close
to existing
students and the normal material
considerations would be assessed as part
of any reserved matters application and
that would include impact on on existing
residents in terms of overlooking and
dominance and all the other potential
effects that the new development would
would have and and again the landscaping
and any screening landscapes grooming
that might be felt to be required again
that would come through and be assessed
and and don't we there was question
about crossing for horses across the a
for one for that is part of the proposal
and that hasn't been something that the
county council is Highways Authority
have have asked for or it has to be
included within hasn't been made for
that and that the first time that issue
has been has been raised I think
commentary' please chairman I have got
loads of gone mrs. Shaughnessy thank you
so much I still am not happy about the
bridle way but part of the bridle we're
going on to wick Hill I really don't
know why the original one isn't used and
why it still can't be used and moving
some of these higher properties Thank
You chairman thank you councillor Swain
Thank You chair when I thought you were
calling counselor heard first sorry
you're right counselor heard Thank You
counselor swine Thank You chairman and
Thank You counselor Swain chairman when
this was initially passed in 2017 the
the applicant was building the road now
why are as it's County Council taking it
on that's my first question
what is the developers contribution and
what is the overall cost I can't believe
that we don't know how much it costs to
build a road going from A to B I'll be
expecting the development to be built
before we have this road it must be
built it speaks of being a relief Road
and that's exactly what it should be it
seems to me that section 106 monies are
coming in from all over the place and to
suggest that that we take the north hey
bridge 106 contributions to subsidize at
Southwold and suburb seems to me rather
odd because north hate which is going to
want all the money that it can to deal
with the problems that there are the
live so I would like clarification on
those please well my understanding is
that the county are not able to put a
figure on what the cost is but this is
great and perhaps for mr. Lee mr. Lee
are you still with us mr. Lee I can I
cannot say and so the first question was
why the County Council and not the
applicant
it was due to a funding issue my
understanding the the relief vote wasn't
going to be on the applicants land but
offending was mostly from other
developers and also the contributions
may have been may have been received
from the developers after the relief I
was actually needed as a payments a link
to the number of houses built on the
Taylor Wimpey site primarily and and the
financial contribution were going to be
paid to the county castle anyway so then
there was there was a new procurement
issue in terms of paying a developer
money for public infrastructure projects
so it was it was it was decided in the
end that it would be much simpler and
much more likely that the relief road
would be delivered in a coordinated and
effective way if the role was taken on
by the County Council and as opposed
also worth pointing out that this is no
the same as a lot of other Road
infrastructure requirements associated
developments the the developer will be
required to make a financial
contribution to the County Council for
off-site Works improvements to
roundabouts for example or widening of
roads providing a bus bus stops and
things the money will be paid for the
County Council and then it will be up to
the County Council to spend those spend
that money and and deliver the
infrastructure works that are required I
think that the first question the in
terms of the developer's contribution
that is in the report so the financial
contribution for this developer would be
1 million
what's over 1.3 million pounds and but
4.4 million pounds had already been
secured as part of site s2a referring to
earlier so that's a combination of
Taylor Wimpey and pres Nicholson also
forming part of the
when South Molton Garden Suburb so if
you add those two together that was
around six million pounds that was
envious that would the road would cost
to build and that was identified and
agreed as part of the the LDP process so
yeah and in terms of would that be the
right thing to do to take contribution
from north hey bridge and I think as
I've mentioned earlier this this relief
Road isn't just serve they all take the
extra traffic generated from south
modern Garden Suburb there will be extra
traffic generated in the vicinity of
this site and as a result of the north
hey bridge developments are going on
there as part of the local plan process
the the cost and and the requirement to
deliver these pieces infrastructure were
were divided up between the relevant
developments it's reasonably as possible
um and there is it certainly one of the
106 agreement for one of the sites in
North High Bridge and the the 106 is
quite clearly being worded in a way that
would allow the money and from that
financial contribution to be used for
projects such as as the South Morden
relief Road and I think at the time that
relief that money was secured it was the
County Council are expecting that money
to be contributed towards building of
the North habeas relief Road but as it's
turned out and the developer the
countryside I think it is they're
required to build the whole of the
relief Road without any financial
contributions from anywhere else so so
there does appear to be some extra money
associated with the North Hobart
developments that could be used if
necessary I mean it that's that's not
the worst-case scenario
mr. Lee was talking about earlier and if
extra money was needed South Maldon
thank you
[Music]
we need to get on unless I haven't I
just want to just want to come back on
that so I understand that the developers
contribution would be 1 million pounds
and the overall cost is 6 billion pounds
is that correct I don't think that is
what miss Matthews said I think she said
that the contribution was 1 point
something million and 4 point something
million from elsewhere she didn't say
that that was the total amount needed as
I understand miss Matthews is that
correct
yes it was that was the sum of money
that at the time the local plan was
being developed and thought that that
that looked like that would be enough to
build a relief road based on the
information that was at the time and so
that's the money that has been secured
through the 106 agreements we obviously
know no one no one here no one can
actually say that is definitely going to
be enough we'll find out that once the
exact cause I think of the road has been
carried out by the County Council and
they are in the process of doing that so
he should know fairly soon whether and
what the actual cost of the Refresh is
likely to be and then when if plan
commission has been granted for the
relief Road then the County Council
think and then look to secure ensure
that the money is available for doing
the relief Road at the time thank you
councillor Swain Thank You chairman and
yes initially when I saw this
application I thought it was going to be
a Groundhog Day as I understand it the
previous application stalled because of
non signing of a section 106 agreement
so if the auto financing of the Ring
Road relief Road has met problem there
then we can be a little bit more
optimistic about the development however
I have a different view about the relief
road and I think it needs to be
rethought and it seems to all this
discussion has been in the absence of
what highways England are planning to do
for the joy of the a12 and it seems to
me it's much more important
modern and hybrids have a decent
connection to the new Junction 21 on the
a12 then this relief road if we do the
this relief road which was dedicated on
traffic from North High Bridge and which
is the reason why it's now been put back
because of the lack of progress with the
North High Bridge Garden Suburb
and it seems to me more traffic is
likely to go if rather than round Maldon
through denry people will want to go
straight up to Junction 21 on the a12 so
that if there is a relief road it's more
like to be per traffic moving around up
to wick Hill them the other way around
I think this father makes that six and
five point 10.12 a little bit and I do a
relevant or at least it needs to be
looked at again we need a a revised
strategic view of the traffic of the
road network from Malden from the County
Council the the relief load has is
linked to some extent with the
development of area for which includes
the community land as as mr. Mann
mentioned there should include a health
center which is desperately needed in
the in the area and but if you look at
the timetable for the staging of this
and for applications for reserve matters
and so on and take the updates we say
the obverse of a critical path see how
late things can happen we could on this
basis not have a community land
available assuming that 1.5 three eight
hours is enough for it which I'm not
sure them and may not have that
available until mid 2030s
I know the highways have said that
they're happy with all housing egressing
on the Lind and roundabouts and the
possibility that there could be a
temporary temporary injunction which may
not be proved to be so temporary for the
area for so I with if that can be shown
to be feasible and acceptable to
highways I would one
to see that area for and the community
land there brought forward to about
earlier stage in the whole process
otherwise we going to be waiting another
ten or fifteen years before was any
chance of getting the community
facilities their counselors fine and
thank you I don't think we were able to
redesign this planning application which
in part you're suggesting counselor
laggin counseling the thing that
concerns me I won't go over is the
health hub the relief Road had not
turned up until 2020 air pollution but
the health hub the detail on that is a
little bit vague to say the least in us
as council suena said with the long
needed medical facilities that this
district deserves and needs is that
going to be adequately provided to but
what I consider to be a nondescript
terminology of a half so what exactly
does that mean and when is that going to
be delivered thank you thank you again I
don't think that that is completely
relevant in part but Miss Matthews
would you like to attempt I mean what
I'm saying is we're not dealing with a
health hub at the moment we're dealing
with the relief road Miss Matthews Thank
You chairman the so the application so
the application refers to a piece of
land before that was phase four Logan so
the community land is identified for
Class C 2 and or D 1 which could include
example hospital a residential care home
clinic health center and or a day center
so at the moment that that is just an
aerial and that's been identified if it
having potential for quite a wide
potentially quite a wide variety of uses
some sort of health hub or clinic or
hospital would would fall within that
Class D one use which this if this plan
permission is granted would would allow
for again the details of any use for
that site would and the phasing of of
the whole development would be something
that will be dealt with as part of this
advance so for as part of any reserved
matters application coming in in the
future
Thank You counselor stamp my question
Thank You chairman Thank You councillor
Sybil Thank You chairman
my concern is and it's not very clear
from the layout and the diagram showing
the access if we don't have this relief
road where will the access be from the
existing roads and how many access
points will there be for what sounds
like three hundred houses and are we
then creating an accident black spot on
the a four one four so could you be
clearing exactly where the access points
are on the diagrams very succinct
question miss Matthews okay thank you
just bringing up a drawing
okay okay which shows it shows that the
housing development would have an axis
off we call the Lyndon homes roundabout
here and that's the axis which the
county council suggested would be enough
at least in the short term to provide
access for the residential development
the employment land which is in this
position here would be accessed off the
existing road network and through
Knowles farm this is again these are
details that would be determined at a
future day in terms exactly phasing of
the development when the relief road
would would be built
when verification of when when it might
be needed and the funding arrangements
available for it so it's not can be
should be decided as part of the current
application if the relief road isn't
provided for whatever reason in time for
example providing Road along the line of
where the relief road might go and I
mean I could that could we seem to be
getting some feedback from you so can
you adjust the mic or something anyway
I paid more to say but the in terms of
access access points and in the
residential would the intention would be
that there would be more than one access
way into the residential parcels of land
in the long terms that you went to the
the relief road is is provided but
earlier then decisions about that the
road infrastructure when it's needed to
be done that would be based on the most
up-to-date traffic flow information if I
think suggested earlier that the 812
improvements might might change what's
needed so but that would all be
discussed and and I said these meetings
are to be there are going to be meetings
with county council offices to discuss
the infrastructure delivery which will
include considerations relating to
highways english plans for the a12 is
the Bridewell be project would also
would change the dynamics of traffic
within the district the whole
potentially so that all the door could
be brought together and thought about
strategically not just this site by it
by itself and there is also the need to
reassess the traffic flows within the
district in light of the the pandemic
and and what you becomes a new normal in
their sort of medium term and longer
term potentially as a result of that
thank you thank you make a comment thank
you very much chairman what I'm really
all so now very concerned about is we
there's it looks like this is one access
point into this site and if there was an
emergency of some sort we are now caught
causing a situation where there's 320
houses with one access in and out which
doesn't sound a very good design to me
thank you
thank you very much now I've got
councillor Darren Morley and white left
to speak then I've also got councillor
Swain who wants to question condition 22
which shall allow and councillor Bamford
which is an additional recommendation
which we'll look at when the speakers
are finished counsel the durham chairman
Thank You chairman we're going round and
round in circles and I think this is a
great danger with overthinking this you
know it's already been explained the
road will be covered with a 106 which is
a legally binding contract so that we
have to deal with at the correct time
the relief road is a relief Road exactly
that not designed as as you will have
just seen there is only one access onto
the development from the relief road
sorry my dog's going mad in the
background so look chairman this is in
our LDP we would be very certainly seen
by things to be unreasonable to refuse
that the the time to go debating some of
the subjects that have already been
raised quite rightly members have
concerned is not at this stage it's at
subsequent stages so chairman you know
notwithstanding the the outstanding
issues which can be done in the future I
think you should move on and get this
get the green thank you now the last
speaker is councillor white that's the
white
Thank You mr. chairman and I've got a
few things I want to discuss and one is
condition 33 due to the London Holmes
wouldn't have been granted if we'd had
the updated conditions their system they
want to make sure it's watertight haha
and I also have concerns about the horse
crossing because we absolutely discussed
that the last honest around and yet it
appears to be missing this time so I
suggest there's extra conditions
regarding the horse crossing the bridle
way I thought
the existing Broadway which was the the
west of the development was still going
to stay there the office I can confirm
that for me the road I also think no
additional funding from anywhere else
because as councilor heard said the
developer agreed to fund that road and I
don't think that any other money we
might have left over should be used to
help her and another developer and I
actually propose that this is deferred
these other questions are answered
because the problem we're at councillor
door exists we'll just agree these
conditions but every time that happens
we get to this next stage with the
reserved matters and we say but we
wanted this pot and they go sorry it
wasn't in the outline so box you know I
don't just ask that condition but I do
want to write I think you should be
deferred so I don't even have enough
information ii did that's a proposal
that's been proposed than seconded I'll
have to take that later
I'll continue now and ask councillor
Swain
what is his issue with condition 22 yes
thank you
that refers to green infrastructure
management and maintenance so did not
include blue infrastructure as well
drainage sods and so on miss Matthews
hopefully they won't be there this this
condition is just about the green
infrastructure management the certain
surface water management got condition
33 him so although the details of
service water drainage would come in as
as required by that condition and there
are a number of conditions under that
heading
talking about surface water drainage and
mater whose water courses and hopefully
that answers that question
Thank You councillor Bamford what is
your additional condition you wish to
the council - thank you Thank You
chairman it follows on from my previous
question now I know that Matt Lee did
answer it but I want to make absolutely
sure this is in the section 106 so I
want to say that I'm happy to propose
the recommend agree the recommendation
subject to the two bullet points on five
ten twelve the report definitely being
included in the section 106 agreement
that that's that's not an amendment to
the conditions but an amendment to the
106 it does say in five ten twelve that
Essex County Council has suggested that
this could be included in the section
106 agreement but I'm not saying that it
is there on the papers make sure it is
what I'm explaining is that is not a
planning condition but that will be
something in the 106 agreement itself
miss Matthews or mr. Lane and yeah okay
I can answer that I think um so in terms
of that that first bullet point in
five-point 10.12 we've and the advice
from the council solicitor is and that
that is not an obligation that the would
or should be in any one Essex agreement
because it's not enforceable it's not
precise enough that's not to say that
that that collaborative working wouldn't
occur that that's going to occur anyway
but that wouldn't be an obligation that
should be in a 106 agreement as safe its
enforceability and and lack of lack of
precision and the other one again
regular meetings that that's something
that it's going to happen anyway
again that wouldn't be something that
would be in a would be an will meet the
test of an obligation within a section
106 agreement you say that meetings will
be happening anyway so in what part of
the conditions is this enclosed with the
meetings and it's it's it's not a
condition it's something that it's going
to be happening always happening already
happening as part of the district as a
whole and the delivery of the
infrastructure that is required for
developments that are identified within
within the local plan many of those are
dependent certainly the highways related
ones are dependent on the County Council
and delivering delivering that
infrastructure using money that has been
secured through various developments
throughout throughout district no modern
high bridge and and being being part of
them so those those meetings I
understood were happening but because of
due to staff leaving and changes they
have gone by the wayside study but they
they are now going to be happening again
so that would involve officers from the
policy section in Malden and the section
106 officer and those those involved
with the local plan and delivery as well
as those necessary people from the
County Council and responsible for and
delivering the infrastructure that that
and and it's all it's all been always
been a collaborative approach because
it's it's that these infrastructure
projects and needs have been identified
by the County Council in the past and
we've worked together to produce the
local plan on identifying the
infrastructure delivery plan as part of
that and so that's something that will
will continue in the future
thank you right now I I do have a
proposal for deferment and and this is
giving me some problems the
recommendation the motion that we're
debating is to agree the recommendations
now although this amendment this yes
this amendment would not negate that it
is it will delay it and I've got a
problem mr. Lee is there a time
constraint on this application through
chairman firstly though I know members
have said they'd like it today
traditional information but I think
officers would like to have it much
clearer what specific information is
that is salt because it may be a case
that officers don't consider it's
possible to get that because this is an
outline application and certain matters
will not be available for information at
this stage with all application of the
applicant has the right to appeal an on
determination if the applicant is
probably fearful or concerned that
members won't support it that may be an
option that the applicant looks at um as
I've said I've got concerned about the
ability for the information that members
are looking for to actually be delivered
to them so it may be that the applicant
would decide to appeal a nun
determination rather than be able to not
provide the information is so a time
constraint
we've got agreement of extension of time
but that would expire sooner than later
and the applicant may not choose to
embrace it so there's always a time
constraint when does it when does it
when does it expire then mr. Lee I'm
sorry to press you yes and end of August
so two white which I'll suggest that the
information that Miss white was looking
for and I think counselor heard on how
much the road is going to cost and it's
not likely to come in before then so
therefore so that informations outside
of the applicants control that is
something that Essex County Council
working on and as explained previously
this is actually while the vote is on
this piece of land the actual funding of
the actual Road is predominantly
facilitated through other sites that
already have planning permission yes
members need to be aware I think I think
you've clarified I'm not going to allow
the amendment mr. white and I will move
to the vote we do this we have to agree
these things then when it comes back at
reserve matters they are so sorry you
agreed it of what you're saying miss
white but I think I need to move this on
could we ask for the horse crossing and
the bridle way to be reinstated but
though I know we discuss them in 2017 I
absolutely know it was discussed well I
didn't think they've been removed
I think I think this is as you pointed
out as Minh that comes up all the time
on this modern South developments and
it's always from memory it's always
there Miss Matthews is that correct new
chairman yes I think um council white
was suggesting that the western part of
the right-of-way was was remaining so
that that is correct the existing line
of the bridle way remains the same it
will be the bit and the section that's
closest to ik Hill that would need
realignment and to accommodate the
relief road
that that as far as I'm aware that that
is the same as what was on the table and
as I'm back in 2017 and there are other
elements or the bride of the bride away
network that will form part of the
development to the south of hospital
Road or the modern Road and in the we
have members have considered the part of
that part of that development made one
and but that by the way will form the
going to form part of them later if you
can identify whether you are for or
against or abstaining please
starting with Chancellor Bamford please
well a chairman I did ask to come back
before the vote because I'm happy to
agree provided I can have the offices
assurance that some legal advice is is
given about incorporating some of this
information in those two bullet points
that I've made just to protect our
counsel because we have an
infrastructure livery plan we need to
protect ourselves councillor Bamford um
I believe that the officers have already
given you this assurance that legal
advice was that it shouldn't go in with
respect is to ask the officers to make
sure that the legal advice includes
something maybe not what that wording
but something because Essex County
Council suggested that that goes in so
something needs to go in to protect our
council mr. Lee thank you chairman and
repeat yourself and thank you chairman
the
the section 106 and the phasing plans of
course the development require that the
either already do require will require
that the road is there to mitigate the
harm in a phased approach in response to
the point about meetings and things
there is always been a collaborative
approach historically meetings had
occurred at the moment ethics are now
looking to work out the funding of it
and I started to use some of this
drawing down money for that until that
progresses there's no need for any
additional meetings but once that has
come that will do so officers will
continue as they always have done and in
best practice to work collaborative this
is County Council and the point is this
isn't an issue of highways to live in a
road this is a combined project for
Essex and Malden District Council it's
our infrastructure it's we only require
cuz the housing that we've required
through the LDP and we will work with
them to deliver it and I think that is
just a standard wording that would go
into any search and o6 for example on
the other two sides so I don't think it
needs anything additional and I do have
concerns anything above that would
actually either be signed by Essex or
meet the legal requirements Thank You
chairman thank you for that explanation
account Tara would you now call the roll
please
thanks chairman now starting cancer
benefit please for cancer passenger
refuse bill for Casa Bell against voice
abstain
Katz's chana or
freeze for Germans
thank you can sit down counselor Edwards
or counsel mrs. Fleming against thank
you sir
that four counts of liquor sorry for
thank you very much
cats the Harker against that's the head
against four keep cats the whole day
Thank You counsel jarvis against against
a star that's the mace against that's
the morni for Morris against counselor
none against cancer Shaughnessy against
that's listed or against yeah cancer
schemes again
that's the stamp again sorry Tara bit
slow on the iPads against thank you very
much
cancer stilts against he counts a Swain
against mrs. Thompson for absent miss
white against it's 9 for 17 against and
2 abstentions Thank You Tara
thank you that is therefore lost and I
ask those that voted against to provide
us with some reasons for refusal please
instant I had sustainable reasons for
refusal insufficient information
relating to the building of the relief
road which should a call into the
original agreement be built by the
developer Thank You councillor Harker
that was what I was struggling for well
said sorry
additions agreed during the original
Planning Commission and have not been
information in these conditions have
been missed off community descriptor
three chairman can I come back on first
obviously this is still the same
application that members looked at
previously this isn't a different
application because the section 106 was
never signed furthermore this site will
provide the financial contribution
required through the LDP this is not
that they are paying less or they're
getting out of any funding this is still
the financial requirement that the LDP
requires which is our policy and whether
or not there is a shortfall is a moot
point on actually determination this
application it's about what was required
through the LDP so
you know this site is policy compliant
in that respect and in relation to
things such as lack of data on the
community land this is an outline
application this is accepting the
principle that there will be a parcel of
land it would be unreasonable to expect
to have any greater detail at this stage
for those points so my professional
advice is I've concerns with those four
reasons - refusal if members consider
such as councillor Wyatt that there were
a couple of points that she thinks could
have been indicated that could for
additionality that's a separate matter
but wouldn't a see for my reason for a
few so thank you chairman what you're
saying is that the reasons for refusal
are not sustained
but mr. councillor Harper's did sound
quite reasonable to me to you chairman
the policy the council requires a
certain amount of funding through the
LDP in this scheme delivers that the
fact that the applicant is no longer
building the road and it's now a six
County Council actually in reality
personal and professional considers a
better situation and it's not to use
colloquialism the applicant getting out
of it as was explained by Miss Matthews
it's actually much easier much more
deliverable for the Karen to deliver it
because otherwise we have to go through
extensive procurement processes through
the Europe legislation and everything
well actually Essex County Council can
just deliver it through the funding so
the points that were raised I actually
don't see as have any planning merit
Thank You chairman money point is
taxpayers money and if Essex deliver it
they can do that if they have to give
money they pick up from the other sites
to a developer there's actual legal
requirements whether or not it's
actually can be done and also if they do
they have to go through a very very
extensive procurement process Thank You
chairman we can disagree with the
phasing as a condition for a refusal mr.
Vallee what's your opinion event three
chairman the facing hasn't been agreed
that is required through the application
so yeah
we review so because it's not on the
table at this moment it could be buried
if we've got conditions that members
aren't happy with we can play with them
but it wouldn't form a reason for a few
I'll okay right I'm going to ask for
after the advice of mr. Li in spite of
the advice of mr. Li I'm going to ask
members to propose some reasons for
refusal because this is what we have to
do we can't just say no we have to have
reasons for refusal that is insufficient
information due to the change of
policies at mulden district councils
since the planning permission was
approved in 2017 can you highlight what
policies of chimes please no I'm so miss
Li can assist mm-hmm she's an allocated
site in the LDP the policies have
changed is it's become more in line with
them not less the LDP was adopted in
july 22 july 2017 this is a policy
compliance scheme on an allocated site
you know the policy the only change in
policy position is stronger not weaker
thank you chairman mr. chairman I have
no confidence that this road will be
built and I do not agree with robbing
Peter to pay Paul
we've got enough development required in
hay bridge without robbing a bridge to
build a road in Malden yes I'm still
looking for some reasons for a refusal
they're not implementable the road will
not be built by County Sherman which
chairman can I ask mr. Li a question
please yes councillors yet I just mr.
Lee will this impact on our five-year
land supply yes well obviously counts
the dam this is one of our allocated
sites and if this doesn't come forward
there will be an impact on
our ability to deliver a fraudulent
supply you know what we've what we've
actively just done then he's open the
door to hostile development reasons for
refusal counsel Morris you had a
suggestion you've done away I was just I
was just noting that Katz lahar cast was
in agreement to the housing in
Highbridge that you know that he's just
that's all I was saying that's not open
a bridge counselor Shaughnessy Thank You
chairman I'm really not sure if this is
a reason for refusal but I would just
like it noted my to two things that I
suggested earlier that care is taken
where the three-story buildings are to
be situated and not right by somebody's
boundary and also I'm still not happy
about the the bridleway
being changed on the onto the wick Hill
Road so I I would like those noted
please but I'm not sure if they are
reasons for refusal Thank You chairman
absolutely this should have been
deferred this should have been - fine
can you switch our video of those yeah
in a minute
they should have been deferred is there
any way we can defer this the the
decision has been taken to refuse so no
we can't because mr. Lai also explained
that to defer it you need reasons why
you want it deferred and he explained
the main reason that we'll see
jested for deferring was the cost of the
road and he was saying that can't be
quantified and it's not likely to be
quantified anytime soon chairman can I
say something please please counsel
stamp and chairman the developer I'm
sure he's very reasonable the same is
modern District Council I'm sure they
don't want to go to a planning appeal
and all the added expense cannot the
District Council and the planning team
speak to the developer after this
meeting who's I'm sure is been watching
this meeting the great interest and say
I'm sure you understand the members
concerns is there anything you can do to
alleviate them and then bring it back
does he have a free go that is going to
be a free cost chairman does mr. Lee nom
and do that that's happened before at
modern districts but also the developer
will will appeal as well as having
another go perhaps I can't say but if
and what we've got at the moment what
I'm dealing with at the moment without
viable reasons for refusal he doesn't
have to worry about the cost of going to
appeal because we'll be paying for his
costs people way around it chairman I'm
well aware that we are liable for the
costs but I'm sure that he because it is
a strategic site is going to be amenable
in theory would have a pre go but the
point is that if members reasons refusal
is that they want information that is
not within the gift of the applicant he
would never be able to resubmit an
application to overcome that reason for
refusal and therefore he would have no
other option but to appeal lack of
emergency access highways haven't put
any in objection but I'm quite willing
to
that Germany is if you say it safety
issue and when the highways we ought we
know highways never ever ever put things
forward to go against any development at
modern district I've never seen one
anyway and so surely it's least it goes
Aloha can we get back to some normality
here videos I'm trying to say that we in
our LD P always said we wouldn't have
cul-de-sacs it was against I can't
remember which blooming design guide or
whatever it was at the time we was
always concerned because it happened it
mole opposite me on the West site we
don't want cul-de-sacs so the shoe
safety information I'm getting I'm
getting a sense that somebody might be
coming up with that counselor none you
wish to speak yes
lack of lack of certainty in respects of
access and infrastructure causing
potential concerns regarding traffic
movement including concerns regarding
emergency services is that seconded
second he thinks of that mr. Lee what do
you think of that we pay him a good wage
he's a good guy I know you think I can
tell you what mr. Daley will say mr. Lee
to previous concerns for my ward members
Shaughnessy's point she said she just
wanted them note it and didn't discuss
where they were reasons refusal I think
they were explained by chance councillor
Matthews Miss Matthews that they
wouldn't really be appropriate for
reasons of use because it's more about a
reserved matters assessment rather than
an outline stage where it's just the
principal I appreciate that but but they
are concerns for my ward members and so
if you could please mr. Matthews make a
note of those it's the height of the
three-story buildings be being close to
be on that site so we can't have that I
would not advise that so easy
notice that you know that they're not
right by current residence on wick Hill
thank you relation to the reason for
view so the Highway Authority haven't
raised an objection the highway
Authority are comfortable with this is
in accordance with our LDP but if
members wished my advice would be that
it's not particularly defendable it's
not at all dependable robustly diffusal
but as always it's in members gift to
come to the decision they come to yeah
members you've heard that that that's
not defendable but it's the only one
we've got on the table for a reason for
a refusal and that will satisfy me at
this stage the members agree that reason
for a refusal
sorry check items and also chair we
could push it in concern that the modern
district council infrastructure delivery
plan will not be achieved
perhaps we could add that in along with
concerns about the one access my my
advice if mr. Lee thinks that's
sustainable or defendable then put it in
but my advice to
council to the committee would be don't
putting too many reasons for a refusal
because they'll be costs if we lose
they'll be cost against each reason for
refusal so one reason for refusal might
protect the council financially mr. Lee
is that a fair summary yes yep food came
in yesterday sir it's always best to
have strongest reasons possible rather
than a a lot of reasons for a few so
Thank You chairman councilor none
tarah did you get counseling nuns
proposal I got a majority I just thank
you chairman I'm not Precious about the
wording so I'm happy for it to be looked
at lack of certainty in respect of
access and infrastructure causing
potential concerns regarding traffic
movement including emergency sir okay
okay I mean can I just for point of
clarity we say lack of certainty but the
applicant has stated where the access is
so there is no lack of certainty we are
a hundred percent sure if members aren't
happy with that that's a separate point
but we need to make sure any reason for
refusal is as robust as it can be
the reason that I'm saying is if there
is a relief Road there are two other
ways on to that site if there isn't a
relief Road there's one you briefed you
refused the app accounts the committee
has refused the application so there's a
channel we have the one application yet
there's been no vote refused we didn't
prove it yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah on this reason for fuser
once it's agreed yeah yeah okay but
that's what we've got Tara did you get
at that time yes chairman thank you very
much yes got that right then I followed
its going to make suggestion if we
haven't had the vote for refusal would
it be wise to take up a counsellor stamp
suggestion and instead vote for
deferment to give them to give the
William has time to he has refused
the recommendation and the application
what we need a substantive motion on is
the reason for refusal for that refusal
so the decision has already been taken
we can't defer unless mr. Lee thinks
otherwise mr. Lee Thank You chairman
the issue is explained that this
information that members are looking for
firstly isn't in the applicants control
secondly is the provision that they're
proposing is LDP compliant and thirdly
is actually a quite a small percentage
of the figure financial figure we've got
coming to us for this relief row from
the other side so I'm unclear on what
the point that deferral would be more
than to say and as I said it's outside
their control anyway when this
information would be so it's not really
a reason for deferral in my opinion
Thank You chairman well actually put
this to members and it's it's right but
if members want to defer it yes good
counsel Morris Oh mr. league
he would use as the most robust recent
refusal what is your advisement through
chairman obviously I've listened to the
debate and I can pull out 16 points that
may be relevant to helped support
members through a reason for a fuse when
I know members are probably quite used
to me doing that my professional opinion
is I've heard nothing in this debate
that forms a reason for refusal thank
you
so I can't my response is that nothing
is a defender will reason for a few so
I've come up with a reason for refusal
councillor Morris however chairman
chairman and most like one angle is that
it's not clear whether the interim
access for area 4 or the community area
is feasible but acceptable it's been
mentioned but we can't be sure that it
will actually work I I have got the
reason for a refusal I don't think that
would help councillors right but I'm
getting the consensus that the members
would like to go back on on their
decision which I wouldn't normally allow
but this is so important and I'll allow
the vote on a deferral although of
course the deferral is not going to
achieve anything as mr. Lee says but at
least it means that the applicant can go
to appeal or non determination at the
end of August yet they would be able to
highlight is that that will not protect
the authority in relation to a cost
claim if anything be potentially more
don't damaging okay thank you for that
advice right I'll go back and say I now
will take apart
on the substantive motion of refusal
with the reason for refusal being that
that's put up by Councillor none and
that was Julie seconded
have you got that Tara yes time did you
want me to read it back Attica
please and this this is this is the
substantive motion of refusing the
application for the reason of what
you're going to read out
chairman Katz proposal was lack of
certainty in respect of access and
infrastructure causing potential
concerns regarding traffic movement
including emergency services all right
thank you put that to the vote always is
everybody tarah call a roll that's the
simplest way Thank You chairman and
members as before start alphabetically
if you could just indicate for against
or abstain please I'm starting to catch
the Bamford please against spiel against
for abstain cancel mrs. chana a go p--
that's the durum he's against thank you
very much counselor counselor Edwards
I'm sane cancer swimming for you can't
surf Luca against thank you catch the
hacker or cancel ahead oh thank you cats
alone hey guys you can't Sahel
councillor hole gates okay against thank
you
capsule Jarvis poor cats Aladdin for
that's the maze for Somali against us
for he counts her none for you can't sir
Shaughnessy Oh fiddle for is for
cancellous stamp for stilts for cancer
Swain Oh
Thank You councillor mrs. Dobson against
Thank You councillor miss white against
a chairman the result of that vote is 17
for 9 against and 2 abstentions thank
you for carried this application has
been refused for the reasons given thank
you can we go on now to agenda item 6
Sherman Sherman just very quickly given
the length of time that has taken I
think as I've said on the chat
councillor chana and I under a
three-line whip to attend a group
meeting at 3 o'clock so it's probably
better that we we leave the meeting now
which is a regrettable but unfortunately
that's taken too long to get through the
previous item thank you do you might
have to explain to members of this
council was what three-line whip is um
thank we moved to agenda item six
planning application for land east of
rebel power station down hill beach
babylon see found on pages one three
five two one seven eight
know that members at play in relation to
this application has been circulated
prior to the meeting contained on pages
7 to 10 and I will ask miss Hernan to
present her report please miss Hernan
show him this full application on sikhs
planning permission to carry out ground
and load test investigations and
associated works including the creation
of to site compound areas and associated
parking areas and it should be noted
that these works are temporary in nature
and they're to help inform the design
and layout of any new nuclear power
station that may be proposed at the site
and to also build on previous plan they
were in their preliminary investigation
is approved and undertaken and taken in
accordance of the 2017 commission and
also its associated discharge of
condition permissions this application
is however for the ground and load
tested investigation most only and is
not for the erection of a new nuclear
power station the works are to help
understand the ground conditions which
may have a direct impact and layout
don't the pets on the layout design and
construction of any future facility here
we have the location plan and it's the
main line around the site and then
there's been some areas within the site
that have been excluded from the red
line boundary as well this is the site
and layout plan so the two areas in the
pinky purple Hatchin are where the two
compound areas are proposed
the load test works would take place in
the larger area and just to the west
that way marks farm and I'll show you
some more details of these and
environment and the ground investigation
compound is just the staff of down all
farm yeah this plan shows the access
routes and the location of the
indicative ground
station works the primary access routes
are shown in the smaller dotted green
line and I'm not sure if you build to
see different joke between them as part
of this slide but basically the primary
routes er sort of around the main areas
and then the secondary access routes
which would just provide access to the
boreholes out to the east of the site
and it's to the north and then we've got
the indicative sighting of the ground
investigation works in the form of bore
holes and trial pits so this is the
ground investigation compound layout the
area will consist of fuel equipment
delivery storage a skip welfare cabin
and parking for up to 24 vehicles and
this is the load test investigation
compound layout the excavation will take
place in the area of in the centre and
the material be stored in Bund in buns
either side to eight meters in these
locations and six meters up here there's
also a pollution control pond within the
northern area and then a compound area
to the bottom down here where room would
be welfare sister sympathies further
parking construction office things like
that it's worth noting that once the
works are complete
this area will be restored back to its
original condition and also that the
compound areas are on existing hard
standing and so there's not requirement
to remove any vegetation in relation to
the area or how many impacts in that
respect this plan shows the earth works
in a slightly greater detail and relates
to the sections that you can see here
and we have some more sections showing
the proposed heights of the embankments
[Music]
it's insight photos from the surrounding
area and also the access to the site
some more photos use it from within the
site and the control tower which is
actually excluded from the breadline
boundary and the more photos within the
site so since the members update was
circulated yesterday which included
letters of representation a slight
amendment to a paragraph five point
three point four of the office report
and an amendment to condition five there
have been some further letters of
rejection received it's not considered
that they relate raise any new material
considerations and largely relate to
ecological and noise impacts of the
development it's noted that a large
number of the letters objection received
previously or also in relation to these
matters and many of objectives of the
principle of a new nuclear power station
that site
firstly in relation to ecology was part
of site does fall within European
designation none of the proposed works
will take place within any of the
protected science also extensive
consultation has been undertaken with
match in England and the council's
ecological sense consulting so subjects
in the mitigation measures the siting of
the works hours of works which all can
be secured by conditions it's considered
that these works except for one
ecological terms and then in terms of
noise the noise report assesses both
ecological and residential receptors it
chews fully risk assessed within the
officers report and there's mitigation
measures proposed including limits to
hours and periods of work so icing of
the works and noise monitoring subjects
for these matters it's considered that
uh noise will be mitigated effectively
and I'd also just like to raise some
members that the mitigation in relation
to noise including ours a similar to the
approach that we adopted as part the
2017 permission and as I've previously
stated this application isn't for a new
nuclear power station so it should only
be assessed and always been proposed
that is the ground works a lot of the
comments we've received relates to the
development control order process
and the principle of a new nuclear power
station but that's not for consideration
so overall and subject to all the
mitigation that's proposed it's not
considered that and the fact that the
works are temporary it's considered that
the works would be largely acceptable
and result in demonstrable harm over the
long term and therefore it's recommended
for approval Thank You chairman thank
you very much Devin right now under the
council's public participation scheme we
have received six submissions five from
objectives one from the Parish Council
on one from the applicant I have
reviewed the submissions and in line
with the public partition participation
scheme can advise that of the
submissions received from eject
objectors only the first submission
receipt will be read and mr. Johnson
will read this out along with the parish
council and the applicants submissions
mr. Johnson please you're very quiet
again move nearer to the mic Thank You
chairman submission one from Linda gimel
an objector this is a speculative
application by a commercial enterprise
that has yet to obtain the necessary
development consent order the
considerable negative impact this work
would have on the sensitive environment
protected habitats local residents and
tourism together with the loss of
amenity due to the considerable light
noise vibration and traffic may prove to
be completely unnecessary and therefore
cannot be justified submission - from
Jean Allen on behalf of Brad Bell on C
Parish Council
although under normal circumstances the
Brad valency parish council would
understand the need for ground
investigations we cannot agree with the
officers report for this application we
consider that none of the development
principles outlined in s1 of the Molden
district plan have been adhered to the
scale of these investigations on our
residents heritage and ecology would be
devastating because of the low line
landscape sound will travel some
distance to have continuous noise and
vibration from seven o'clock in the
morning till eight o'clock at night
plus weekend workings will affect those
living in every part of the village
including the school they are zone a
community is a place for quiet and
contemplation and yet is one of the most
affected areas for noise and light
pollution our world war ii airfield is
not only an important part of our
heritage aid memorial to those who gave
their lives for this country but is also
a huge tourist attraction the runway on
the airfield would be destroyed beyond
repair huge bore holes were dig within
the vicinity of the hangars it is
claimed that the damage will be
temporary and nothing other than visual
however it is not possible to return the
environment to that prior to the work
the submitted BRB ecology report is
taken from out-of-date records and is
inaccurate some data nothing more than
remote sensing there are concerns noted
from the Essex Wildlife Trust and the
RSPB and the RSPB concerns over the
limited data the fact that no nocturnal
surveys have been submitted or data on
the water voles and Imbert invertebrate
species of the river waymark mold and
council are not able to determine
whether this proposal will lead to
adverse effects on this important
our area this application does not give
definite sites or locations of proposed
works so why has it been submitted
before accurate details are available
even if Maldon District Council is
minded to approve this application we
trust that you will defer a final
decision until detailed information is
provided mr. Johnson just interrupt you
before you read the next one to say that
we did actually have another submission
from a parish council I think Milan
Parish Council but they were out of time
to include in this agenda thank you
would you please carry on Thank You
chairman submission three from Andrew
Murdock a project Development Director
and the applicant firstly we would like
to thank the committee for allowing us
to make representations today we would
also like to thank officers and consul
tees for their work on the application
and to members of the public that
submitted their feedback we are seeking
planning permission for ground
investigations on land adjacent to the
existing Brad ball Power Station as the
committee will be aware this site has
been identified by government as
potentially suitable for a new nuclear
power station this means that the
government considers that this site is
appropriate for a new nuclear power
station in principle however the local
impacts of the project need to be
considered thoroughly through the
development consent or the process with
the Secretary of State ultimately
deciding whether they are acceptable the
investigation works that we are applying
for today are required to inform the
design of the proposed new Power Station
that in turn will be consulted upon
through our statutory consultation
before then been applied for through the
DCO application the works themselves are
detailed more fully in the officers
report but in summary these comprise
exploratory investigation spread across
the site a load test investigate
focused in the center and to temporary
site compounds on existing hard standing
areas the investigation works are
temporary and are anticipated to be
completed in two stages of November 2024
the ground investigations and October
2022 or the load test elements once
finished the site will be returned to
his former condition of agricultural
land the application is supported by a
suite of technical reports which have
assessed the proposed works and have
been considered by statutory consultants
as part of this a package of measures is
proposed to manage the works and
minimize impacts on ecological receptors
and neighboring residents this includes
measures to control noise levels in
accordance with the proposed planning
condition and submitted noise appraisal
which are secured through the operators
contracts and will be monitored against
by qualified personnel we will also
regularly keep the local residents of
Bradwell and the Parish Council informed
of what's happening at the site this
application is not for the proposed
power station but it is necessary now to
inform the ongoing design of the power
station that we ultimately consult them
and apply for and ensure that its
effects are fully understood and can be
appropriately mitigated our work on the
bread will be proposal are ongoing with
the extended stage 1 consultation
closing last Wednesday we are continuing
to develop our proposals and will work
with the council statutory console to
use relevant bodies and the public in
Forth coming months and years before
submitted an application for a
development consent order Thank You
chairman thank you very much I'll now
move the recommendation is that seconded
it's not seconded yes we now put it open
to members and I have a long list
starting with councilor laggin Council
again
Thank You chair I'm gonna rationalize my
list because there are so many members
that deserve to speak but I just want to
talk about a few things that stack out
of the officers report to me they've
caused concern then there's some points
and there's also some questions so if
you'd be gracious with me I'll go
through the points and then I'll ask the
question at the end we talked about in
Sexton 3.25 old investigation would
involve trenches 200 meters by 100
wide 810 meters deep with further
excavations to the bottom of the
excavations but if we don't give any
detail on the depth of those further
investigations they can three point two
point six we talked about all holes
being only indicative even the site plan
and generally note location and I don't
think that's a detailed enough
consideration we talk about three point
two point one three with working hours
which has been touched upon but the talk
in the officers report about daylight
hours only I don't believe that's
outside our archive committed in the LDP
and therefore a breach of our own policy
and conveniently enough a lot of that
will be done in summer which was caused
a great amount distressed at the
residence in the area three point three
point one says it would not have a
detrol impact on the character and
landscape of the area so these massive
of trenches spoils and lorries loss of
ecology and nuisance to the residences
and classified as harm I want to check
that when point five we talk about main
considerations of our own policy s one
the 5.1.1 presumes in favor of
sustainable development and we talk
about the efficient use of energy
renewables coastal management
mitigations against flooding running
point four of our own policy we talk
about of always flood zones two and
three which it doesn't in this this
potential excavation work in point five
it says to conserve and enhance the
natural environment well it's clearly in
breach of that in point six uses convert
conserve and enhance the historic
environment further down in the policy
talks about where the locations of the
to be therefore you are going to touch
on an impact historic environment our
policy and d4 to support is being
reviewed so that's a statement that
we've already agreed at form Council and
eken
sweet our own policies going forward
five point one point seven talks about
employment the employment will not be
localized we will not have the benefit
the economic benefit that it brings in
because it would be a migrant workforce
because we just simply do not have the
expertise in the district to do some of
this work having worked on national
infrastructure projects across the world
I know that five-point-two talks about
visual impact on the area we talk about
a high quality built environment members
this is not five point two point two of
the NPP F talks about good design making
areas better for people this proposal is
festive works and it compounds doesn't
what I with that the side compound with
the puns talks about ten meters still be
visible would that not be materially
harmful five point two point ten we
would not encroach on the natural
landscape and result in characteristic
in the loss of character in the area or
surety that's in that clear reason for
refusal final meaning their chair five
point three heritage in our fellowman
our ecology five point three point one
talks about for grade 2 listed buildings
and they're admitted from the boundary
line interesting five point three point
three we talked about likely to harm the
blister hangars they will be overwhelmed
in the size of the spoil piles five
point four point three into policy all
developments then seek to deliver non
net biodiversity and then five point
four point five of the report says that
works are not predicted keywords to
cause adverse effects that cannot be
guaranteed because the prediction is not
a guarantee five point four point seven
boreholes do lie very close to areas of
the Barrow dike and therefore there
would be a functionally linked land loss
five point four point nine share says
that the light and visual news
disturbers will occur here has to
McLaren works like this as mentioned in
five point four point one five the RSPB
have grave concerns and the impact
five point five the impact on the
environment the conservation enhancement
of natural environment is a key
principle in the NPP F and the LDP this
work goes directly against those
principles 5.50
has a limited development in the past
was a contamination does it not concern
members about the contamination risk
that will come out five point five point
one two will cause harm because of noise
the threshold would be higher the
residents will be impacted policies be
one more therefore would not be followed
and ever would be in breach of our
policies five point six point two the
vibration will breach the one and age
for policies five point six point six is
the worst case scenario it says each
borehole will take two weeks or if Ike
members to go into research and how
these bore holes are actually drilled
and made they have their hammers in
essence and they talk about the noise
receptors being fix the 8la eqt which is
DBA they may go up like ten percent that
puts it into additional area of harm its
stipulating the report that harm
additional mitigant will be needed they
would be visually screening therefore
there would be material harm five point
six point nine talks about the times we
talk about 1900 hours chair to 2300
hours
that's outside around policy that's in
white in the in the in the report so
finally with the government concern over
Chinese business partners which this
application is made from I'm very very
concerned that one policy and so we were
doing ourselves and our residents a deep
deep deserts thank you thank you very
much I know mr. Lee wishes to speak but
my intention was to leave most of your
questions to allow Devon to to refer to
them all and however mr. Lee mr. Lee
Thank You chairman sorry it wasn't I
just obviously like to come back on a
couple point to just talk about the
principle of the scheme obviously I
think some members may be looking at it
disproportionate th what the application
is
plan application is for groundworks the
works that they are looking to do our
temporary in nature there are conditions
relating to that there are conditions in
relation to noise mitigation and matters
such as that the council has a policy
which is adopted that is our policy at
this time for planning applications that
we support the principle of a new
nuclear power station any decision
outside of the local plan process
doesn't change the council's current
position in relation to its local plan
that will be the legal basis of any
future appeal what adults like say is
that obviously if you're looking to
build an extension on your house you
have someone come around to make sure
there's no trees nearby and things like
that this literally is just that sort of
development expanding up it doesn't
facilitate per se will go on any
indication that we're supporting the
nuclear power station it is literally
just an application for ground works it
could be in theory for a runway or a new
thousand houses obviously the works
would probably be small would be smaller
in that respect but that's the point
this is a application for what it is a
members must determine the application
in front of them not what they consider
the application to be but solely for it
a lot of the matters I think that have
been raised tying to further
considerations and further concerns
rather than the applications in front of
them and there's once against that this
is an application for temporary works
they these aren't permanent so certain
concerns that may be had that might
remain if this was a permit wedding but
in five years time these developments
all these this harm will have been
removed and that needs to be a
consideration by members when looking at
the application Thank You chairman wagon
I was going to say mr. leaf thank you
for that explanation but councilor
laggin referred to the report and raised
a lot of issues that were contained
within the report we
I'm hoping that this hona will be
addressing but as I said with councilor
leggins permission I'll leave it for
some while because I suspect that other
members that wish to speak may be
raising the same mid shoes and so if
that's agreeable to counsel it laggin
thank you very much indeed cuz I will
proceed to counselor nun thank you very
much
in addressing my comments can I please
draw the council's attention to our
issue 5.3 heritage I find it somewhat
ironic that this council has just
adopted and approved a list of local
heritage assets for Brad war these
include all that's left of the airfield
buildings and the airfield sides itself
which isn't much nowadays five point
three point three admits that that some
of these assets will be overshadowed by
these works and it goes on to talk about
a detriment of significance even our
conservation officer has expressed his
concerns particularly about the
landscape although it says that this
will return to its original condition in
five years they can't possibly return to
its original condition based on the
proposal and will it really after five
years or will it be forgotten over time
just as appears to have slipped the
memory of some people of the great
contribution that was made by the
personnel of re F Brad will bei during
the Second World War
surely we can't toss that memory aside
by these inappropriate works thank you
very much sir Misun and if the
paragraphs counsel none refer to the
list that counsel a leg and he's
and if they're not would you add them to
that list councillor Bell Thank You mr.
chairman so it took me a moment to
unmute their Brady Council nagging has
made most of the points that I wanted to
make very very eloquently Thank You
Council again but with all due respect
to mr. Lee 78 decibels from dawn till
dusk for five years is not really the
equivalent of doing an extension on your
house these are very very intrusive
works that breach MDC's own unsafe and
the environment you cannot return the
environment to the way that it was there
are endangered species sensitive sites
it's just these works not the power
station itself these works will cause
irreparable damage and contravene our
own policies so and additionally how can
we how will be discussing this when the
government itself is now questioning
whether it will move forward with
Chinese involvement in nuclear power
only two nights ago there was an MP on
that news night saying there are
questions over Chinese involvement so
this is very very previous to be
considering digging up the Genji
peninsula for something that is likely
to never happen so I urge members to
refuse this please Thank You Jana
councillor maze councillor maze are you
there council mouse yes yes sorry I had
problem with bus yeah my phone yeah I
think a lot has already been said can
you hear me
yes okay lovely thank you I think there
was no mention anywhere as to the
detriment to to humans is there's quite
a lot of Paris ecology but actually
there's no mention how residents living
in the Brad we'll see Brad well village
telling her Matilda den G and beyond
beyond or actually
going to be affected by this again the
long hours a 7 a.m. star actually in
reality that could be a 5 a.m. start and
the disturbance I to have noted as
councillor Bell did that this
contravenes our policy on the level of
noise these levels are it says in our
own LD P we says we should we should be
preventing these were the impacts though
on the actual boreholes themselves every
single console T has actually raised
concerns about this you know RSPB
interesting that natural england
withdrew their objections but there we
go
many species are noise sensitive that's
just not a hearing noise but it's also a
seismic noise none of that has been
addressed there is no information on
that impact that will be made there's
also no I think on the ground water
problems that may be experienced
including the water table bore holes are
used across the world to actually buy
water so it's quite likely that these
bore holes will find water what will
then happen to the surface and beyond in
any of the dikes are etcetera the
Environment Agency has also raised more
questions than answers
it is very unhappy with the lack of
information that has been provided by
the applicant for this ground work
application we might support this in
principle I'm not sure that I would have
supported at 20 at times the size but
nobody has actually addressed the the
social impacts and the harm that that
this development is actually going to do
Thank You mr. chairman Thank You Council
mates councillor Bamford
well we we know that the principle of
nuclear is agreed by this council and we
know that the government has agreed
Bradwell for nuclear but what we don't
know is whether anyone has agreed such a
large-scale proposed power station and
that's what concerns me
there's planning applications for
groundworks investigations but it
wouldn't be so large if the proposal of
the power station wasn't so large so
we're talking over 200 bore holes and
that's not a figure that's laid down
anywhere it's sort of a proposed amount
so there could be more than that I did
contact the offices and I raised various
queries with them and they very kindly
answered gave me lots of good answers
but I'm still concerned about
enforcement and we know that enforcement
is difficult the conditions have got to
be enforced and this is going to be a
problem if it goes ahead so there's very
lots of unknowns and there's lots of
questions about wildlife noise hours of
work and on that basis I'm not happy to
agree this officers recommendations
however Germany if members are mindful
of agreeing it I would like to propose
some amendments to conditions if that
comes to so at the moment I want to make
a proposal to not agree the officers
recommendation on the basis there's no
evidence the massive scale of the
proposals you can't make a proposal
because there's you can make an
amendment but you can't make a separate
proposal because we are debating the
proposed and seconded recommendation at
the moment however we will note what
you're saying later on in the debate
thank you chairman if you could come
back to me I would like to make an
alternative proposal if the first
recommendation fails thank you thank you
very much councillor Flemming Thank You
chair I just wanted to draw members
attention to page 143 five to seven the
officers wording whilst the buns created
at the load test area site compound
would be fairly high up to eight meters
just to put that into context that's the
height of a telegraph pole I would like
one of the officers to confirm the
actual acreage of the load test
investigation site compound please thank
you should be a simple equation for the
councillor Fleming will put it to them
in a minute that council swine
[Music]
thank you German and yes first of all
food comments I do think the hours of
hours of work need to be looked at and
as far as for homes and Sarla concerned
the report does refer to maximum numbers
so I don't know whether one needs to cap
the numbers once they've said that what
I would like them to come up with this
minimum number I mean in this situation
the technicians are likely to go mad and
say we want all these full homes over
the place I wonder whether there's a
minimum number that they feel is
necessary
secondly the load test area seems very
large hundred metres by 200 I don't know
if that it doesn't seem to be the
location where they would put this the
the main plant the reactors so I don't
know where that is excessive as far as
period of noise I assume that most noise
is really in the preliminary few months
rather than throughout but as to
restoration I can't see any reason for
allowing them five years to restore the
site once they've finished with their
monitoring I would like to see them do
more work in the following areas on
radiological contamination
what they say they've done is merely a
desk exercise this seems to me quite
inadequate particularly as there may be
existing information already available I
would like to have more on the impact on
aquifers of their drilling and how they
would dispose of drilling fluids I think
they need to have a look at reducing
noise levels working to lower thresholds
for noise levels and they were for and
their information relates to noise and
vibration I think also ought to take
into account the impact of infrared very
low volume throbbing effect of the
action the activities and as far as of
geological information I would have
thought that already was quite a lot
that they could refer to but they don't
seem to have reference that at all and
my last point and there is a reference
or comment by the officers that there
would be some local employment as a
result even in this of these first stage
activities I don't know whether that's
just a sort of general statement or
whether they have any particular kinds
of business and activity in mind I think
Thank You councillor Basinger Thank You
mr. chairman mr. chairman I'd just like
to say that I agree with them pretty
much everything that's gone before
especially councillor Langham and I
understand that this application is for
site investigation and not a power
station but let's not be misled or
divorce divorce from the fact that this
is the cornerstone for a much bigger
picture an impasse here 200 bore holes
drilling down to a hundred meters deep a
hundred metres by 200 meter low testing
area about 10 metres deep I think it
says noise pollution of the
275 DB 75 decibels is very very noisy
indeed lively ain't what it 78 there you
go even more light pollution working
from 7:00 a.m. to 8:00 p.m. six days a
week especially in the winter this site
will have to be floodlit so there will
be light pollution waste water pollution
there'll be extra lorries carrying
massive drilling equipment building
materials aggregate coupled with the
workers cars will create huge increase
on traffic and using the existing
infrastructure to sell this lovely new
roads already the traffic here is
terrible there will be massive negative
impact on the wildlife marine life and
it will impact on our heritage sites and
sites of conversate and commerce
conservation it will have a negative
visual impact on the landscape these
these mounds are huge it will also have
a negative impact on the people that
live here and the surrounding areas the
LDP says in principle the council will
support a power station but it doesn't
say in principle it would support a
power station 20 times the size of the
existing one in my opinion we shouldn't
be selling out and we shouldn't sell out
for a bag of beans with a 106 agreement
stamped on it thank you very much mr.
chin councillor schemes as a final
speaker hi well okay I asked the
question why Brad well be in arguments
in favor of this application and the
associated borehole drilling for a new
Power Station as simply this temporary
disruption return for new jobs a boost
to the local economy and a partial
answer to the UK's desperate need for
efficient power sources to close the
energy gap and that do not tour out pour
out tons of greenhouse gases into the
atmosphere
this is what this is about these
considerations have recently outweighed
my concerns about nuclear safety and
local impact because the technology has
improved I'm not a scientist or an
expert but I do write about technology
and I figured with new technology we
could have a safer plant more powerful
than Brad well a
I'll call the old one but on a smaller
footprint something that in fact turns
out to be totally possible so not fresh
hell is the current form of this bread
well-being monstrosity with all the
boreholes and other planning issues it
creates is something of this scale
needed at all that is the fundamental
planning question that is pertinent to
this application do we need something on
this scale as councillor Bamford has
asked shouldn't new technology require
less space not more do in order to do
the same thing if you look at your phone
watch how it's dropped from being a
Motorola brick by your ear in the 80s
and now it does so much more and is so
much smaller it is the nature of
technological advance for technologies
to become more compact so what on earth
is going on here now I think I'm right
in saying that Brad will A's two
reactors put out 300 megawatts at their
peak in 68 Brad well B requires 10 times
the space to put out six times the power
that's ten times the space including
four massive buildings each 200 foot
high far higher than the original Brad
one reactors how is that an advanced in
technology Brad well B is expected to
cost twenty billion what we're nobody
really knows but if Hinkley is anything
to go by it's going to be more is there
an alternative the answer is yes Rolls
Royce are among a number of leading
technology companies creating small
modular reactors costing about two
billion that the figures aren't clear
yet each and they put out 450 megawatts
that's a hundred megawatts more than
Brad world's A's two reactors at their
peak as I understand it now that is
technological progress and all on a
building footprint of one and a half
acres set in a 10 acre site not the 450
acres that Brad will be seemed to be
requiring it seems that five of them we
could put put out the same fat power or
more than Brad well B for half the
expected cost and acquiring a fifth of
the land have you had a look have you
seen them I'm just going to show you now
a quick picture of the
of what I'm talking about I'm hoping you
can see that can you see that
okay well I'll shirt you later if you
can't but here's my my point the point
is simply this that that's a maximum
height of 16 meters that's 53 feet not
200 feet times four and with a 60 year
working life so here's the thing they
would be British designed British built
and British Oh owned and indeed we we
would we need five on this site one
would put out more power than Bradwell
aidid and we could supply chilled food
Colchester and Southend and everything
in between which of course is a Morden
district is that not a no-brainer isn't
it kind of isn't isn't soon the
government gonna wake up and say
actually come on we're going to do
something about this this current
configuration makes no sense to me at
all and therefore all these boreholes
are not needed not yet that this
potential white elephant this potential
white mammoth needs further an
investigation so I think I've been
accurate on what I'm saying I'm open to
persuasion but I think we need to pause
and look at this more carefully and
check the alternatives before we
devastate this area seriously we need to
pause voting against this will in my
view give us that pause and Thank You
Council shown here I apologize I appear
to have thought you'd spoken but I must
have missed you
councillor Shaughnessy have you've given
up on me councillor Shaughnessy
sorry chairman can you hear me now yeah
I apologize I thought you'd spoken yes I
did I did hear you thank you thank you
chairman I appreciate that I've several
points I've agreed with everything
everyone has said so far everyone's been
very eloquent and covered lots of ground
which is amazing I would just like to
say that the government has not agreed
Brad well at the moment it is still only
a potential site which the letter from
the CEO that mr. Johnson read out also
pointed out and the government energy
white paper is still pending not least
of which I don't suppose because the
government have had you know rather a
lot on their mind with the pandemic
pandemic at the moment so that white
paper has not materialized yet we are
awaiting it so why the haste here really
why the haste and I like counselor
passenger I don't think that these
ground works which as everyone has said
will be hugely devastating can be
divorced from the the whole bills and I
would just like to furnish counselors
with a few facts which may well come out
in the in the white paper at least some
of them nuclear energy is twice the
price of that in wholesale energy
markets the council mr. Shaughnessy I
don't think this is really relevant to
our debate I think the bills cgn and
China you know these these groundworks
won't decide whether it goes ahead or
not just how it will go ahead and I and
I and like councilor Basinger I can't
divorce the things but I would just like
to
say a few things about nuclear energy
will you know decide whether this whole
thing goes ahead or not because you UK
energy to Hampshire as fallen by 24% is
down you drive despite a population
growth of 10% can you try and make your
comments on this planning application
and not a nuclear power station or the
nuclear power energy that the hey let
the lady speak I appreciate what you're
saying chairman but I do think lots of
things are important I do have a
question for the offices someone has
already mentioned that Essex Wildlife
Trust in the RSPB have spoken against
this and although these are wildlife
enormous ornithology experts why was
only the view of the National Trust
taken forward who are not experts in
this that's a good question thank you
did you want to say anything else
if councillors have time and I think I
think we'll pass on the facts for the
moment because I want to come back to
the officers on councillor logins
detailed paragraph by paragraph and see
whether they have managed to formulate
some answer in response to to council
elegans comment so I think council
dragon probably covered nearly every
issue but there were one or two other
issues Devon that came up so would you
like to try and answer all these
questions Thank You chairman and I think
I made a note of the majority of the
paragraphs but it's probably best if I
take it and sort of on a subject by
subject so such noise character and so
we can address it all that way rather
than paragraph by paragraph and
hopefully if I missed anything
members will let me know so in terms of
the character in appearance of the area
and the works are temporary in nature
and it is conditioned that this site
will be restored to its current
condition
once the works have been taken place so
any visual harm is considered to be
temporary and given the extent of the
site as well and the fact that the
material that will be stored will be
natural materials and its officers view
that the long-term harm wouldn't be
significant and detrimental in terms of
the heritage and the impacts on the
world war two hangars whilst there would
be again some temporary harm in terms of
visual impacts on them it's not a
structural concern it won't affect the
actual integrity of the structures
themselves it's just going to be a
visual impact and again that is
temporary and we propose conditions that
will ensure that this site is that the
site is put back to its former condition
and there any impacts on that those
hangars will be addressed over time so
again for those reasons we didn't
consider that the harm would be
demonstrable over the long term in terms
of sorry just taking them often so go
and I think Council like I mentioned
about there not being a net biodiversity
gain so a lot of a lot of my responses
are going to be to do with the works are
not permanent and as the site will
return to its former state its
considered that it should go back to its
current biological and ecological state
as well a what what would happen
as part of the any future application of
the power station we'd expect to see a
landscape and ecological strategy as
part of that and so that would perform
it that would be something that needed
to come forward as part of the wider
proposal rather than these works at the
moment but because these are temporary
it wouldn't be reasonable for us to
require them to implement net
biodiversity gain at the moment and it
should the site should refer back to its
current biodiversity value and once the
works are complete residential amenity
and the impacts particularly on noise
and light have been addressed within the
offices report in relation to different
properties we've been the SIA and these
whilst there are it's noted that there
are sensitive areas within the site
where noise actually I think one of the
references that accounts also referred
to over these 78 decibels this is based
on a worst-case scenario
so we've mitigation measures imposed and
which are both in relation to the time
well that's can be carried out and where
they can be carried out it's likely that
the the noise won't exceed the threshold
this as I said earlier this is approach
that we adopted as part the 2017
permission as well so we wouldn't be
doing anything that we we haven't done
before of thumb recently to do so
previously and also in relation to the
ecological receptors I think the closest
one is 950 meters away so whilst on the
plans it may look as though it's they're
very close it's a yeah 150 meters is
quite a distance and that there will be
monitoring taking place during the works
at those sensitive sites there's also
conditions proposed at whether in the
sensitive areas works can only occur
during one hour for certain hours of the
day so if anyone's
I think it's condition I'll find it now
but yeah what's the one in the condition
prevent any works and taking place for
exists excessive periods near the most
sensitive residential receptors did have
another points make on them in relation
with oh and also in the hours of use at
the hours of work so there's conditions
to prevent works taking place during
certain months of the year also whilst
the hours in general fairly wired as
I've just said there if there's
particularly concerned insulation to
particularly sensitive areas then the
hours have been reduced in those areas
to make sure that there are no
detrimental impacts on either ecological
receptor the residential receptors just
probably worth mentioning them that as
well the environmental health pink
resulted and a happy of those findings
that probably brings me on to the points
in relation to light so the light the
lighting proposed in within the
application site are only limited to the
compound areas and as a condition that
both natural England and the ecology
consultant have been consulted on that
ensures that they won't crater and
unsuitable and unnecessary light
pollution within the surrounding area
but there's no need for any other
extensive flood lighting or anything out
further on the peninsula relation to the
boreholes or any works taking place
there did you do the next point I picked
up was in relation to employment and the
report acknowledges that there would be
thirty people employed at the site which
it does acknowledge that they probably
due to the not that they would probably
come in from the outside of the site
just crisply specific
the area to to the specific specific
skill set that they require but there
will be some economical benefits to the
local area in terms of them being within
the site ups through seeking
accommodation and things like that
through the time but we do notice that
is there something of limited weight but
is is something to be considered I think
there were some points mentioned in
relation to flood risk so 2016 at the
boreholes would be in flood zone 3 but
given their nature and they'll create an
increase in flood risk or pose and or
post money and human risks in relation
to food risk they there is a suitable
management plan put in place which will
include responding to the employment
agencies flood risk warnings there's a
fashion procedure the low test area and
the compound the other compound area in
flood zone 1 and then the only part of
the low test area which which is within
flood zone 3 is the spoil storage area
but given the size of the flood plain as
a whole and the limited size of that
area and it's not thought that that
would increase flood risk elsewhere and
I think forgive me I forget I forget
which member asked but there was
somebody asked for the area of the
excavation for the load test the the
main excavation in the center would be
twenty three point six hectares in area
so that that's the 200 by 100 meters I
think that covers everything but if I've
missed anybody's points please do let me
know I think I think Devon there was an
issue about Heritage wasn't there yes so
that was what was referred to in
relation to the hangars and the World
War two hangars and the water tower yes
so the
and the world war ii hangers are
actually in closer proximity and than
the control tower in relation to the
development - given that we found that
there's not substantial harm in relation
to the hangers it's not considered to
any of the other designated these sites
would be impacted on in any greater
sense okay thank you
councilor laggin I see you mrs.
Shaughnessy councillor Lagan I think
Devon has tried to cover most of your
issues but is there anything that you
don't think she's covered well firstly
chair thanks for the responses I'm still
concerned that the responses in line
with the detail in the report and the
points that I raised earlier on I still
stand by because we talked about that
the words should we talk about lighting
but no Lux reports yeah we talked about
it's been done before but that doesn't
mean that this shouldn't be looked at
differently 30 people not at the site
the flood risk we're acknowledging
things in the report that we say that we
won't allow within our policies and
therefore I still stand by the questions
that I have although I appreciate the
officers answers Thank You counsel mrs.
Shaughnessy you my question wasn't
answered by death and I'm afraid I'll
repeat it for her and the Essex Wildlife
Trust and the RSPB I have objected to
this some application and although these
are wildlife and ornithology experts why
was only the view of the National Trust
taken forward who are not the experts
because obviously you know the ecology
of this area will be severely you're not
messed about with 11 a policy to help
counselor as soon as I saw you I thought
I missed that one
so we've is not that we've not
taken into consideration in the view of
Essex Wildlife Trust or the RSPB
but natural England are the statutory
console to and for these matters and
they have provided a response that quite
other people respond simulations the
application and they don't raise any
concerns
so as the statutory console to and in
this instance this is a view that we've
we've taken we have taken the other
reviews on board and address them within
the report but and yes I say the natural
England is the statue constancies there
okay Thank You Devon but but I still you
know the RSPB for instance has made vast
you know recommendations here and I
thought they should have them had more
prominence but but thank you for your
answer and thank you chairman councilor
none you want to come back on heritage
yes thank you very much chairman and
thank you Devon I know this will
probably be seen as a very narrow point
but to me it's an important one and not
just me but to many other people
there's an odd notion here in terms of
heritage conservation to say that there
won't be any damage is just not true the
enclosure and the boreholes based on
that plan seem to be on and going
through part of the runway and perimeter
track so how can that be temporary and
how can that damage the repaired and
reinstated with all of that work taking
place it will prevent their visitors to
this important historic site for a good
five years and actually in five years
time probably all of the Aria veterans
that we have left will be dead the poor
Devon thank you so in terms of we'd only
vision there being any structural
impacts on the existing heritage assets
in terms of anything to do with
archaeology or
heritage in that sense there's a written
scheme of investigation it's being
conditioned or proposed to be
conditioned so that if anything is
within the site during those works and
that could be dealt with appropriately
and but I think we subject to the the
conditions that we're satisfied that
there wouldn't be and long term harm
other than the visual impacts that will
occur while the works of carrion taking
place to the the heritage assets
councillor bill I have Thank You mr.
chairman and again I know with respect I
what I'm hearing here is harm doesn't
count as harm if it's only temporary and
I entirely disagree with that
furthermore some of these things can't
be got back once the species has been
you know killed off is a bit is gone
it's gone you can't get that back it's
not just temporary and cats the maze
mentioned the size make impact briefly
the effect of vibration on these
heritage assets of which councillor none
has spoken
um could be terminal really and in the
amount of vibration that is gonna be
caused by these ball holes we cannot
cannot a food to underestimate the harm
permanent harm that will be caused by
the harm is harm whether it's temporary
or permanent I'm sorry thanks mr.
chairman Thank You councillor Bell right
that concludes all the speakers so I'm
aware of councillor Bamford wishing
perhaps them to suggest something else
but for the moment I shall moved forward
with the vote on the recommendation and
the of approval and with the conditions
members be aware of the earlier debate
so Tara would you take the roll please
thank you chairman members before and
you could indicate for against or
abstain please start
councillor Bamford cancer average all
against passenger against some appeal
against bow against that's the boys
abstain cats the Edwards against cats
ERISA swimming against thank you cats
off Luca I'm chairman I'm excluded from
voting under wolf four point nine degree
most meetings hope Nicole so I'm not
doing either as Odin I'm just excluding
thank you very much
catch the Hawker heard against Thank You
counselor helm cats the helm counselor
home again thank you
Catholic Jarvis videos counsel again
again cancer maze against ollie against
cancer Morris me against Chancellor none
against Shaughnessy against Chancellor
Siddal against Queens against
against our Thank You stilts against
Swain against thank you counselor mrs.
Thompson and stain absolute miss white
against SAR it's counselor tell me I've
done if you got my against or not no
thank you
and I'm just gonna check Harper again if
he's present chairman she's gonna make
sure he's not on the list bear with me a
moment
no I think she must have dropped out
said earlier a prejudicial interest
didn't they queue interest so we leaving
yes nobody's 4:22 against and two
abstentions
Thank You Tara that motion is therefore
lost and I now need I'm sure I'm going
to get plenty reasons for a refusal and
I think mr. lien might be able to help
on this occasion tonight chairman I do
have some reasons I would like to put
those to mr. Lee for his comment please
donate councillor Bamford so the reason
against would be that there is no
evidence the massive scale of the
proposals have been agreed by government
making it necessary to undertake
extensive ground work investigations
insufficient information and concerns on
the effects of Wildlife and heritage
sites three Chairman obviously that I'd
split that into three various reasons
refusal which the first one relates
really to the prints with the new
comparison this application isn't for
that it is for the ground works and
these are necessarily for the
consideration at the DCO process so I
will advise against that as a
refusal it doesn't really talk to this
application it talks to the future I
just clarify that though because the
reason why they're having to do the
extensive groundworks are purely because
of the scale of the proposal so it is
relevant you can understand what counts
bump it's coming from but that relates
to whether or not there is a need for a
nuclear power station of this scaffold
that's what these works are required to
facilitate and she certainly it's
putting the cup for the horse and I
doubt my professional opinion is such a
recent refusal would be very dangerous
I'll move on to those two obviously
officers do not consider there's an
impact on the ecology especially take
into account the environment agencies
and the natural england's responses but
obviously members that's within their
gift and assume officers have raised or
didn't oxido there's too much more harm
taking account of temporary nature of
the development on the historic assets
but once again offensive members don't
agree with that that's within their gift
okay thank you that that is two viable
reasons members I've had a suggestion
and which I've lost now while the
reasons could be a detrimental
detrimental impact on the character and
landscape of the area also Fleming
suggests would that be a viable one mr.
Lee once again obviously concerns for
that is relation to the fact this is a
temporary development that in theory is
going to be returned back to the state
it was if the new news the power station
doesn't come forward and therefore you
know members need to consider how much
harm is actually from this application
in relation to the character and
appearance the area Thank You chairman
noise impact mr. Lee C chairman and I
members raised this and I know
Oh Ernest I know miss Lawson right dealt
with this I think quite eloquently
during the debate you know while this is
a worst-case scenario there are
requirements within we can be
conditioned that I'll suggested that
would mitigate the harm and bring it
down to the numbers required to be
acceptable therefore I'd have concerns
with the reason for use one noise and
servants because of the fact that the
condition could overcome those in office
okay to suggest something well so it's
slightly related because the whole point
here is is that they need these bore
holes for a massive development that is
unnecessary now we have agreed as a
council in principle with a nuclear
power station we have not agreed in
principle with a massive power station
and therefore we don't need all these
both bore holes and and in order to
Justice to make this speculative sit a
disruptive drilling of 204 holes in
order to try and support the production
of technology that is already outdated
strikes me as madness it's so I would
say that it's definitely relevant to the
so it's it's a sort of premature
premature application with that knowing
what size but we do know what size they
want to put in we know what size they
want to put in and we're saying that
they what I'm saying is that they don't
need that size because I've already
demonstrated that they don't need that
size through Chairman my advice is that
that is something for the DCO and not
for the local authority and that should
not form a reason for a few so I would
think it'd be a very dangerous direction
to take out I think members as I advised
before and when you're making
recommendation of refusal of an
application it's best to keep the
reasons for refusal as few as possible
and unless unless you have got sound
planning reasons to
to put them in as reasons for refusal
we've got at the moment I suspect to
subjective reasons which I'm quite happy
to move forward to final question and
scale because mr. Lee's always talking
to us about both different applications
and how to some of the valid reasons to
not accept them so surely with members
video 22 against the open scale that
could be a valid reason for full or
futile but I suspect that it's a broken
scale is only on the buns and that's
only temporary but mr. Lee that's not
problem yeah I would have concerns about
the ability to argue that the buns in
this site in the buter are available etc
and the temporary nature that would be a
defendable reason for a few so decision
makers with your professional opinion
would steer in a song what we can and is
a defendable reason if focus mr. Lee
[Music]
officers have a problem when they've
given their professional opinion members
have overturned it mr. Lee is always
very helpful we have got two reasons for
refusal but mr. Lee is content with
everyone say he's happy with them but he
is content with them just a question
wishing to speak before you cancel stamp
if you don't mind counselor now
thank you very much chairman so five
years of Lima on the wildlife heritage
caliber landscape of the area which was
built by this council to be irreversible
okay mr. Lee is that an objective my
advice still stands in relation this
point you know five years in the
lifetime of a development in the long
term when we look at planning you know
that goes back to 1947 now and five
years is not a long-term harm there's a
level of subjectivity and I think as
I've explained you know I think there's
some leaning she may be more towards
disturbance to birds in the short term
but things such as the impact in the
character I don't think of five years
would be in the big picture seen as a
defendable reason for a few so Terra's
telling me off we should be using the
chat to wish to speak counselor none you
can say something and then I'm going to
councillor Thompson I'm just picking up
on what mr. Lee said really you know
that that was that the second part of my
proposal was that that this council
feels easy reversal yeah exactly right I
think I think we can probably go with
that
councillor Thompson Oh Thank You
chairman I'm actually going to say to
members can I suggest as the Chairman
already has in mr. Lee already has pick
your battles stick to subjective reasons
that we can justify because if we go
against that professional advice weren't
hiding - nothing mr. Lee is the one as
our other of our professional officers
he's the ones with the degrees and the
masters and to be honest I'm very
to accept that if he says that a reason
isn't them to stand up that I believe it
really isn't gonna stand up so please
members pick your battles it's important
that we win them and not have a
scattergun approach with every reason we
can think of Thank You chairman Thank
You counsel Maurice you want a question
how's the Maurice yeah just getting the
arm chat function thing trying to work
yeah I've just suggested that mr. Lee
has heard the [ __ ] that by he knows
pretty much everything that's been said
and can we not leave it to him to pick
out the best reason for beautiful.we we
have already decided that there are two
subjective reasons that mr. Lee is
comfortable with or content with if not
comfortable so we'll move on I think
that's all speakers we'll move on then
to take the I've been trying to speak
this I have issues with technology at
the beginning of the meeting chairman
and can I just ask you to reiterate the
decisions or the reasons for refusal
what members because I'd like a set up
Gandhiji so we'll be on the table
chairman yeah we're going to do that and
now I also got somebody else that wants
to say something but no because I
depending on what's on the table it's
depending if I say something chairman is
that okay yeah okay tarah can you help
us with the two reasons that we've got
because they've gone under my radar at
the moment to my understanding members
the first one was relation to noise and
disturbance on ecology matters obviously
officers will make the beams of fuse
with a is the application is refused a
little bit more robust but that would be
the main thrust in a similar one in
relation to the historic environment
I know there was other ones relation to
noise and disturbance just generally
which I wouldn't encourage members look
at another one about impact on the area
bulk or anything along those lines which
once again I would not encourage and
obviously there was the one that just
little bit more recently about that the
council doesn't think that the site can
be returned to its former appearance but
I've got concerns that come see we've
got conditions that empowers it would be
required if you you know you'd need to
have some sort of assessment of why you
felt that obviously members don't have
that in front of them Thank You chairman
can I ask now Thank You mr. Lee not try
and help to support by actually what
cats are none has been saying very
eloquently all along its protecting our
heritage and our assets surely that is
defensible in a court of appeal when we
are actually we have got a duty of care
and cats are none very eloquently said
about the history if you're gonna dig
bark boreholes
you're gonna change the whole say in a
hundred years time somebody wants to do
some ecology to find out some
archaeologic information you've
disturbed it and also the other Essex
chairmen I'm not going to bang over it
again but can we not have to think about
protecting our heritage please uh mr.
Lee three chairmen that was the second
one I just said she was she and I just
wanted to put some meat on the bones I
didn't get it all in quite detail I
wouldn't recommend that we came up with
the exact wording right now as always
I'd recommend we come up with the
objection and then that's delegate to
officers currently exact wording but it
would be on the relation to the harm of
the archaeological assets which are yeah
okay Tara are you happy with that
there's there's two reasons around those
two issues that the officers will put
the work
chairman counts the swag now his hand up
for a very long time he's very patient I
think people have missed him he's been
at the top of the list for a long time
and everyone else has been coming in I
apologize counsel this morning thank you
Tim and yes I have had a wedding for the
refusal but in principle I think we
ought to include there is a lack of
technical information I was going to say
and it overlaps perhaps to some extent
what has been said inadequate
information about the scale and nature
of proposed investigative operations and
their impact and a need for tighter
restrictions on operations I don't know
that is specific enough for mr. Deane
well I think I think I think mr. Lee is
advised on this that this sort of thing
can be done by conditions in mitigating
and but mr. Lee and what's your comment
on counselors wines for you chairman I'm
unclear on what the lack of information
is because I think officers are quite
comfortable with the information we have
with us at this time fair to assess the
application if members weren't happy
with certain restrictions that have been
suggested as just said by the chairman
that would be a case of additional
conditions or variances to the
conditions that we've suggested rather
than a reason for a few years old Thank
You chairman have you got an idea for
the word chairman Lee mentioned first in
relation to noise and disturbance on
ecology matters the second in relation
to historic environment but also making
mention to archaeology and the heritage
assets thank you would we add that the
officers will form you like the wording
for this in consultation with myself
perhaps
and any anybody like to suggest anybody
else know in consultation a members
happy with that so I'll put the motion
to refuse with the two conditions for
refusal subjects of the wording being
checked in consultation with myself is
that is that correct Tara
yes Jenna okay of course chairman and so
members asked before and if you could
just indicate if your four against all
abstaining started me counselor Bamford
please thank you or for some SPO or four
counts the boys abstain he can select
let's oh sorry hi Tara
um councillor Thompson's just raised I
lost my connection very briefly am I
able to vote no very briefly yes but if
the man signed the legislation does
allow for dropping out of internet but
if it was more than anything than that
then it would be now Matt could you
define very briefly then I don't know
legislation allows literally for you
internet to drop out and to come back
sort of an instant if you were if you
missed any of the debate the law would
still kick in that you shouldn't vote I
did you miss much of the debate um sorry
Jim no I didn't miss any I was just
trying to help out with a couple of
people that were mentioning they miss
missed bits and all I want to do is
protect the council in its decision I
don't know interfere with anyone's right
to vote just to make absolutely sure we
don't do the ranking I'm happy to vote
I was just raising the issues just in
case I'll go for the minute my advice
would be if you did miss bits to quote
count stomps would be you don't vote
because you weren't available it allows
further to stop and to reenter but if
you have missed any of the debate and I
literally mean any of it I would advise
you don't vote because that wouldn't be
would be challengeable okay so I missed
a couple of minutes switching to a
mobile Rooter when our connection Pelt
so I won't they'd thank you thank you
very much Casa Luker he said that he's
not voting didn't mean that's right yes
sir yet and cat suhaka I think he's left
did you say yes hmm
Casa hurt yes I'm for refusal on the
noise and disturbance and and vehicles
entering and exiting the site as well
okay yes I support refusal thank you
cats ahem for thank you can you hear me
yes got you thank you very much
counselor Jarvis poor thank you cancel
again before you catch some rays for you
counts the morning he's left the meeting
hasn't he sorry capsule Morris
definitely for thank you much counseling
none ball think you can sir Shaughnessy
or you can sister door for Ames sorry
for thank you cancer stamp thank you
much
cancer stilts for cancer Swain
oh thank you cancel mrs. Thompson
abstain I canceled miss white or salsa
Batphone is 24 nobody against and 2
abstentions Thank You Darla that motion
is therefore carried for a refusal with
the two conditions as outlined I now
move on to agenda item 7 business by
reason of special circumstances
considered by the Chairman to be urgent
I had none are therefore closed the
meeting at 1622